And we're live.
All right,
Shawn,
welcome aboard man.
Thank you.
Thanks for doing this.
Appreciate it.
Thanks for having me.
Joe.
You are one of those guys that,
uh,
that came up so many times on twitter.
I had to reach out to you.
So many people were like,
have you checked out what this guy's
doing?
He's eating nothing but meat and he's a
doctor.
He's super healthy.
I was like,
okay,
let me check out what this guy's doing.
And then I saw you and I was like,
he's serious about this.
And I was like,
okay,
this isn't a gimmick.
You're actually an educated guy and um,
you,
you are pursuing this carnivore diet.
Yeah.
I mean it's,
you know,
if you were to ask,
pull this thing up close to you,
if you could let you go,
if you would've asked me two years ago,
I would've said,
that's fucking crazy.
I mean,
yeah,
it's what I to say,
you know,
if you'd asked me even five years ago,
I'd say,
yeah,
die doesn't really matter that much.
Just training your ass off.
Because I had been an athlete is
training my whole life.
And you know,
I didn't really until I got in my mid
forties and then all of a sudden I was
like crap,
trading ain't working.
I'm just getting fat.
I'm getting,
you know,
high blood pressure,
probably pre diabetic and they're not,
you know that I went down this,
you know,
there's dietary journey where I went
from doing the low fat,
low calorie fish and vegetables,
almost vegetarian training three day,
three times a day,
just about trying to try and get lean.
And then I went down to,
you know,
then I was like,
man this sucks.
I'm miserable.
I can't,
can't,
can't maintain this,
you know.
Then I went on the Paleo Diet.
You started looking,
I was like,
man,
Bacon looks pretty good.
And then I went and I started reading
some more and then I went on to a low
carb,
high fat.
And then I did ketogenic for about two,
three years.
Cause I think you do stuff like that
dude.
And then I just started reading about
these people that do this cardboard dot.
And then I want to sort of reading,
did you read about it?
Well,
there's,
there's actually a facebook group,
it's called zeroing in on health is
getting Charles' Washington,
he's been doing it about 10 years.
And so they've got about 10 thinks about
13,000 peoples right people.
So He's been exclusively on a
carnivorous diet for 10 years,
10 years.
So no vegetables,
no carbs,
no nothing.
Nope.
I mean he basically eats,
you know,
I think he ate steak and pork ribs and
stuff like that.
And there's another guy,
I mean it was more impressive.
There's a guy named Joel Anderson and
his wife Shawn,
they'd been doing it for 20 years and I,
you know,
I could probably show you a picture of
that guy,
but he,
I mean he's 60 and he looks like he's 30
his wife is in his mid forties and she
looks like she's 25 I mean there,
I mean why all by looking at these
people you're like,
they're crazy healthy.
You know,
what happened was she had lyme disease
real bad and was kind of overweight and
really sick and he started doing like
the same stuff loud when he's reading
about these olds cold bodybuilders,
you remember,
I don't know if we're ever going to
convince Kuranda.
So he promoted the steak and eggs diet
back in the 1950s sixties and he was
just jacked.
I mean he was,
he was like,
this is,
you know,
1956 he was kind of before most of the
steroid stuff was hitting,
you know,
I mean there were,
there were still some steroids back in
the 1940s you know,
they're Nazis play with that with the
truth.
But you know,
it didn't really get into the
bodybuilding culture till probably the
60s you know,
and in the 70s and not,
you know,
not to everywhere.
Right,
right.
But he was doing this stuff when he,
and if you look up,
if you look up Vince Garon de and look
at his physique from the 1940
[inaudible] 1950 he's fricking pretty
amazing.
And it's just eating meat.
He was eating his diet was basically,
I think it was five days of just eating
meat and eggs.
I was taking the eggs and then every,
every one day,
like every fifth or sixth day you could
eat,
you know,
whatever.
And so that's what,
that's what he did.
So that was his night.
So that's what he looked like back in 19
you know,
that's probably the fifties you know,
so.
So that's pretty decent for back then.
You know,
they jack,
well I mean for,
for our,
and for a nonsteroid guy,
I mean this is also taking into
consideration how little they really
knew about training back then,
right?
Oh yeah.
They didn't know.
I mean,
if you go back into history and I'm
moving to talk about that,
but then there was a guy named Larry
Scott who was like the first Mr Olympia
and he was another guy that was eating
just tons of meat,
you know,
four or five pounds of meat a day.
And he wanted us to an Olympian again,
you know,
there's some of their drug use,
in some of this stuff.
But I was just reading about this stuff
and I was just like,
well,
I'm,
you know,
I'm an athlete.
I like trying new stuff.
And so I said,
well,
I'm just going to try it for a month.
And so I did it for a month and I was
like,
man,
I feel pretty good,
right?
So I was like,
well,
I'm gonna,
I'm size like I did a month.
And I'm like,
well,
I'm gonna go back and go back to my
Kenogenic Diet.
And so I started wearing that day.
The day I did,
I was like,
I'm gonna eat some apples,
a little almond butter,
you know,
had some barriers and creamy and stuff
you'd be normally it is a treat and I
just didn't feel as good,
you know,
like my back started hurting a little
bit and I was like,
well,
maybe that's where someone had,
so then I went and said,
well,
I'm just going back to eating meat
again.
When your back started hurting from
eating apples.
Well,
I mean,
it was just like,
you know,
this is one of the things that I've seen
him,
and we can talk about this,
you know,
in detail,
but I've seen a lot of people what
they'll say is,
you know,
and this is what I saw when I was
working as a surgeon,
when I put people on a ketogenic diet,
their joint pain was starting to go
away.
Right?
So this is pretty common.
A lot of people believe that joint pain
is connected to the consumption of
simple carbohydrates.
Well,
I think,
yeah,
I think it's,
you know,
I find carbohydrates,
I don't know what it is for sure,
but it's something we eat and most like,
you know,
a lot of cases,
not always,
but I think there's something out there
we're eating.
I'm pretty convinced as not meat,
you know,
that's what I can tell you for sure.
From what I know,
you know,
whether it's,
uh,
you know,
sugar,
whether it's,
uh,
you know,
process gluten or wheat or stuff like
that,
whether it's vegetable oil,
uh,
whether it's,
you know,
or even some vegetables potentially.
And so this is what I'm seeing and this
is what I saw.
You know,
I studied these large facebook groups
like an anthropologist,
you know,
like they used to study these people,
a hundred years ago they'd go out,
you know,
western price,
we got and see all these people and
study their teeth and stuff.
The problem with that is,
you know,
you don't speak their language.
You know,
he was pretty remote.
You can't,
you've got to translate.
And so some of those observations,
you know,
while they're valid,
they're hard to do now,
you know,
but so when you go on these groups and
you just wa all even knew it,
just like reading this,
like a scientist going,
okay,
this guy went on this diet and has joint
pulling away.
And this guy,
one of those not in his thyroid disease
went away.
This guy went on this diet and his skin
got psoriasis,
want to go.
And I kept seeing this over and over and
over and over again.
I mean thousands of them.
But the big thing for most
people is removing refined
carbohydrates,
removing sugar.
And a lot of people
dairy.
Yeah.
I would say that that's a good strategy
for most people.
You know,
here's the deal.
I don't care what people or you didn't
eat,
whatever makes you healthy.
You know,
I think this is a thing.
We had these national guidelines that
tell people what to eat,
but there they don't work for most
people.
You know,
obviously,
I mean,
we're looking at it,
look at our country.
I mean it's just,
it's sad to see all these people that
are,
you know,
really,
really getting sick.
And so I think,
you know,
there's a guy named Vinnie toward her
two has this no sugar,
no grains.
I think that will,
that will successfully help a huge
percentage of people,
you know?
But I think you have to be objective
about it.
You have to do it long enough for town
and effect.
And you know,
I think you have to,
um,
you know,
being,
be really cool.
It'd be really clinical about it.
And so one of the big problems that I
see as a physician,
and this is a big problem because people
will go on a low carb diet or ketogenic
diet and they'll say,
I feel the best I've ever felt in my
life.
I mean,
my mood is better,
my,
my mental cognition is better,
my joints feel better,
my guts don't hurt,
my skin is better,
my sex drive is better.
Everything you would say is that means
you're getting healthy and they'll go to
their doctor and they'll get some blood
drawn and their cholesterol be high and
the doctor will say,
well,
you're going to kill yourself.
You're going to have a heart attack.
Right?
So people get scared away from that and
then go back to eating their other stuff
and they get,
then they feel crappy again.
But they're like,
well,
at least my cholesterol is not bad.
So one of the big problems,
and I'm trying to sort of basically
preaching this stuff is I think,
and this is a problem with health care
in general,
is we have so gotten away from just
defining what's healthy.
You know,
if somebody comes into your office and
you say you meet,
you talk to him for two,
three minutes because health healthcare
is just,
you got 10 minutes to see a patient make
a decision.
So what you're gonna do is like,
hi,
how you doing?
Order a bunch of labs.
You look at the results of the labs and
say,
okay,
this lab's low,
the slab is high,
the slabs normal.
Go on this drug or you know,
do this or that.
And,
and in,
in the patient may be saying why,
but I feel great.
Or the,
or maybe converse,
they may say,
I feel like crap.
Well,
you look at your labs,
look fine.
So go exercise a little bit.
So let me
back to the beginning.
So you,
you're,
you're a physician,
right?
So you understand a lot about the human
body,
double you worried when decided to go on
this carnivore only diet.
Well,
you worried that you were going to be
deficient in some sort of nutrients and
vitamins and fiber and all these
different things.
Like where were you cautious?
Yeah,
I mean,
I,
I was very,
uh,
very,
I'm still skeptical.
I mean,
I mean that's just the way he should be.
But I mean,
I was,
uh,
we're aware of what's not in me.
You know,
if you look at the Rda,
if you look at the already in it says
meet as low in vitamin C,
it's low and manganese,
it's low and you know,
a potassium,
it's low and you don't vitamin a.
But I mean there's a whole bunch of
things.
It's low and you know,
on paper,
right.
So I was like,
well,
I don't,
I can't rectify,
why are these people are doing so well?
You know,
just eating meat and we know
historically that tear their populations
out there in the inner what the Messiah,
the Sammy and all these people,
you know,
and the,
anyway,
it's probably the best exam,
but
right.
Because they had extremely low incidence
of cancer and no,
there's nothing up
there.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know,
if you go to,
if you go to northern Alaska in the
winter time,
good luck trying to find a fruit or
vegetable or not.
And so,
but what people would say,
well they would,
they would just,
they would just fly.
So yeah,
but they had a lot of their organs and I
guess the vitamin C from their liver and
you know,
some of the,
some of the whale skin handsome.
And so they would just try to justify
that and try and make,
this is how it worked.
And then the same thing as messiah.
And they would say,
well sometimes they would eat some
berries once in a while.
So they would always try to justify it.
I'm like,
you know,
those things aren't available year
round.
So you know,
you can't get berries,
you know,
especially in Alaska or wherever the
anyone are.
You know,
you can't,
you can't get that 12 months out of
year.
That's not what's having a significant
impact on their diet.
I don't think it's coming from the meat
itself.
Well,
this was,
this is what,
this is what I,
after doing a lot of research on this
stuff.
So we've known,
so it's interesting.
So when we look at the development of
the Rdh,
you know,
the recommended daily allowance is those
were divine,
those were developed back in the 1940s
and they were developed basically for
soldiers to figure out what the heck are
you supposed to feed people so they can
survive.
And so they did research on this and
what they did was they take populations
of people that are consuming a normal
diet.
Like you know,
back in the 1940s you know,
people would eat a mixture.
Everything was fairly high in
carbohydrate,
not as high as it is now,
by the way,
but it was a mixed diet.
And so what they see is,
you know,
if you eat that diet and you're
deficient in this nutrient,
if you don't get x amount of this
nutrient,
you're going to develop some sort of
nutrient deficiency syndrome.
And so they said,
okay,
well we know that this level of nutrient
deficiency causes disease,
so therefore we're going to recommend
this.
You know,
everybody gets this amount,
right?
So,
but they knew what they found out back
even at 1897,
there's a study where they're looking at
animals and they looked at something
called firemen.
They didn't know it was time and back
then,
but they saw that certain animals,
if they're on a lower carb diet,
they didn't get this disease.
We're animals on a high cart
carbohydrate dig this disease.
And the disease was called Berry Berry.
And so that's a thiamine deficiency,
which causes neurologic problems or um,
uh,
congestive heart failure type problems.
And so they were noticing that these
animals are on a low carb diet,
even though the thymine levels were
really,
really low,
they weren't getting diseases.
So if you look at that and you look at
all these other nutrients,
you know,
things like manganese,
manganese is highly,
uh,
required for carbohydrate metabolism.
And so if you're on a diet where you're
not taking any carbohydrate,
all of a sudden you've got to say,
maybe I don't need as much manganese.
And despite what the RDA says,
and you can look at that for nutrient
after nutrient glucose and vitamin sees
a huge one,
right?
So vitamin C,
you don't,
you don't take vitamin C and you get
really,
really need to get scurvy and you get
sick.
You die is it will kill you.
I mean,
you end up with bleeding in your joints,
your teeth fall out,
your gums rot,
your skin opens up with sores,
horrible disease.
And these people are not getting scurvy.
And so what's happening is we know that
a molecule of glucose and a molecule of
vitamin C are almost identical.
And so they compete for the same
transporters.
And so if you don't have a lot of
glucose floating around,
you need way,
way less vitamin C.
Really?
Yeah.
So there's,
there's some,
and this has been known for for quite a
while as well.
So,
well that's fascinating because
obviously orange juice,
tons of glucose,
tons of vitamin say.
Yeah.
Right.
Database account,
cancel each other out.
So I think what's happening,
and this is one of the things I think
potentially it just needs to be
investigated,
but I think that a lot of people that we
have all these vitamin deficiency,
vitamin D deficiency,
magnesium deficiency,
a lot of that may be caused by just
ingesting too much carbohydrate and
creating it,
creating a higher than normal need.
So basically we're,
we're creating higher needs for
vitamins.
Now.
You do blood work on yourself.
I haven't,
you know,
I haven't yet.
I'm gonna probably do it once I get,
you know,
I'm,
I'm a year at this.
You haven't done any?
No,
I don't.
You know,
here's the deal.
Do,
I mean I've got a lot of people to do it
all the time.
I'm not that interested in it because I
just don't,
I don't think it makes that big of a
difference from me.
I'll do it just out of,
just to satisfy other people's
curiosity.
I don't really have that much curiosity
personally
about your blood work.
I would not really radical change in
your diet where you're just consuming
only meat.
I would,
I would want to see what kind of results
I'm getting.
Well,
I mean it,
I mean it depends,
you know,
if you can tell me what blood tests
tells me I'm healthy and I don't think
you can't.
Well I think if you get a really good,
yeah,
doctor who understands the different
genes,
hdl cholesterol and ldl cholesterol and
free testosterone available and all the
different nutrients that are essential.
And if you get someone who really
understands that and kind of a
comprehensive examination of your blood
work,
I think he could benefit from it
greatly.
But also the,
the knowledge that you can tell them
like,
how do you feel?
I feel great.
You know,
and they can get a look at this.
What are you eating and what kind of
media you eating?
Where are you getting in it?
Yeah.
So that's an interesting point cause I,
you know,
we've started this,
and again,
I was new,
I started doing this and got public on
it and twitter and a lot of people were
saying,
well,
yeah,
you're,
you know,
you're doing well.
You're,
you know,
I'm breaking some more records and stuff
like that.
So let's put,
explain that.
Like what raw world records he,
Bryce,
so on the,
you know,
so I've been in,
yes.
So I've been an athlete my whole life
taught me and I've,
I've done,
it was like an athlete look pretty
stellar.
I mean,
you know,
I'm about to 40 right now,
but I mean I was,
you know,
so when I was,
when I was younger I played rugby in New
Zealand.
I was playing with some of the all
blacks,
you know,
at a high level.
This is before it was professional in
the name of the team by the way.
No,
it's not a race plane with blacks.
Is that what he's saying?
There's Zealand all blacks.
Do you want to know the history on it?
And it's kind of an interesting sort of
thing.
So back,
you know,
back in the 19 hundreds of New Zealand
guys were so fast and there's forwards
and backs,
fours elect the lineman in the backs of
the fast guys and they,
they were all so super fit.
And so they said they looked like they
were all backs,
but somebody type made a typo.
So that's what I'm,
that's interesting.
But they're,
they're like the best rugby players in
the world.
You know,
some people say South Africa is pretty
good,
but New Zealand is pretty much the best.
So I played down there with those guys
and then I went into weight,
powerlifting and I had an American
record in the deadlift.
I was deadlifting close to 800 pounds is
drug free athlete back in the 30s and
then I went on to 'em,
I just am strongman stuff for a few and
then I went on to throwing,
you know,
like track and field,
like discus and shot put and then the
highland games where you,
you know,
you run around with a big caber and wear
a kilt.
And I won the world championships in
that.
And then you know what I got in my mid
40 [inaudible] I was about close to 300
pounds back then I was about to 80 to 85
and I was like,
man,
I just can't keep me doing this side.
So that's when I started dieting and
stuff.
And so I got down to pretty lean about
two 40 ish or I'm at now.
And I started doing is indoor rowing
stuff,
which is not a concept too.
So you remember,
I don't know,
you know conor mcgregor on is,
I don't remember that machine he was
rolling on.
I mean I'm sure in a lot of the Mam
showing guys know that.
So I got on there and I started training
for that.
And so what I did was there's a 500
meter row,
which is,
you know,
and this is kind of itching because it's
highly,
highly glycolytic.
I mean it's,
it's like,
it's not like running a marathon,
like exact pitter explaining glycolytic.
So glycolytic means you're burning
glucose,
you know,
you're using muscle glycogen,
I know he had,
who's a fell on a couple of weeks ago.
No,
it was,
the other guy was Andy Galpin.
Yeah.
He was saying all you got to have
glycogen.
And I'm like,
well to do highly glycolytic activity.
And so this is a highly,
highly glycolytic activity.
Takes about a minute,
a minute,
a minute to minute 30 and that's,
that's intense.
You know,
like you're going all out.
Right.
And so I was able to break the war,
the 50 plus world record in that.
And it was when I went Olin,
when it was uh,
when I got to 50,
it was one minute,
18.3 seconds.
And so I put it down all the way down
and one 14 so it took four seconds off
the world record without a single gram
of carbohydrate.
Totally.
I mean,
but doesn't,
when you mean this is the,
one of the issues with the ketogenic
diet,
if you eat too much protein,
your body converts that Protein Back to
glucose.
That's one of the things that they were
saying that you have to have like the,
you,
you're supposed to have like somewhere
in the neighborhood of 70% fats,
30% proteins,
right.
So this is a,
this is another sort of thing that I
think a lot of people sort of have,
have questions about.
One of the things we know about
Gluconeogenesis,
so that's converting protein or fat into
glucose is it's demand driven.
So your body doesn't just make it.
So if you get a lot of protein,
it doesn't just say,
I'm just going to make a bunch of blood
sugar for the heck of it because your
body doesn't need it.
And so one of the things that glucose is
extremely important to the body.
I mean,
we need it.
I mean it's absolute.
So the nice thing about it is if you
regulate it really,
really well and the best way to regulate
it really,
really well,
it's just to make your own.
So rather than,
you know,
getting it from Kombucha or you know,
eating a bunch of carbs,
you know,
we're,
we're going to be all over the place.
So this is what happens.
So,
so ketosis,
again,
I probably spend significant periods of
time in Ketosis,
but I'm not always in Ketosis.
And that's not the point of this,
you know?
But I mean,
I think it ptosis is probably a good
thing,
you know,
periodically.
But I don't,
you know,
like I said,
I don't think,
you know,
we,
we can talk about evolutionary,
excuse me for interrupting you,
but why would it vary if your diet's not
varying?
Why would you be in Ketosis or out of
Ketosis if you're not varying your diet?
It just eating only meat.
Right?
So,
you know,
because it depends on how long I go
between meals.
Oh self,
I'm not intermittent fast,
so I intermittent feast.
So,
so this is what I think is,
you know,
I think this is probably more pri.
I will often go,
well,
here's the funny,
you know,
so I was in Denver,
a couple nice guy.
I went to the big Brazilian,
you know,
get down all you can eat meat place and
I just to Haas Korea.
Yeah.
I just picked up.
So I went there and I just,
I had him come back 50 times.
Wow.
Like I clicked everyone,
I said 50 frigging orders of food I had
to pay was about six pounds of meat and
hundred putting away in one setting.
You ate six pounds of me.
That's insane,
dude.
Yeah.
So I would,
so I put away about six pounds and then
I'm not hungry for like 30 some hours.
So I'm basically,
it's not that I'm intentionally,
fasting is just,
I've faced it so much that I just don't
feel like eating.
So I think here's what I think,
Huh?
You know you haven't,
why do you think we have an appetite?
I mean,
what's the point of an appetite to tell
you when to eat,
right?
Right.
That's exactly right.
But if you're eating the crappy wrong
food,
you know your appetites all screwed up.
So one of the problems,
we have people eating the wrong food.
You know,
we have this,
all this process garbage.
It's full of calories,
sugar and crap,
but it doesn't have any nutrients in
there.
So every time you're hungry,
your body's saying,
give me more nutrition.
Well,
if all you do is pour garbage your body,
you're always going to be saying,
I'm hungry,
I'm hungry.
Plus the insulin spikes,
all that stuff.
I mean,
so you want to know insulin is not,
you know,
we need some insulin,
we need insulin for muscle growth.
It's,
it's a useful thing.
The goal of insulin is not zero.
You know,
that's what people,
you don't understand.
It's not,
we don't want our glucose to be zero.
We don't want our insulin to be zero,
but we don't want it always,
always,
always spiking.
And so,
you know,
when you eat a big meal of something
you're supposed to be eating.
And I'll argue that I think meets a
pretty damn good meal and we can argue,
we can talk about how it's completed,
not,
but,
um,
so when you do that,
you know,
you dislike the next time you're hungry,
it's time to eat.
Your body says I need some,
I need energy so you can get it from fat
when you eat meat.
But I also need structure.
And so by you know,
eating meat,
you know,
you're basically giving your body what
it's asking for.
And I think that works pretty well.
Whose phones them on?
That's very interesting because,
uh,
most people would say you should eat a
balanced diet.
Right?
Most people would say that in order to
be healthy,
you should consume certain amount of
fruits,
a certain amount of vegetables.
You should have some,
some whole grains,
you should eat some meat.
And if you come along and tell people
like,
this is what I'm doing,
I mean six pounds of meat and I don't
eat for 30 hours,
like this guy's out of his fucking mind.
Yeah,
I mean I agree.
I mean it sounds crazy,
you know,
2017 that's crazy.
It's crap.
I mean I can,
I can point to thousands and thousands
of people and doing it in an excellent
help,
which is interesting.
But I mean,
you know,
balanced diet is just a frigging cop
out.
I mean it's like,
I don't know what that fucking to tell
you.
So I'm gonna tell you the mom's diet and
I wish you had done some blood work so
you should get us some data.
I mean,
it seems like someone who's espousing
this diet,
like it'd be nice he had some hard data.
Yeah.
So I mean,
you know,
cause I didn't know I was going to do
this.
I just started doing it.
I'm like,
well I,
you know,
I've already done it,
so I'll,
I'll probably get some,
you know,
so what,
what did you just decide like,
hey man,
try this for a month and then just keep
going.
I've tried.
I said I'm going to try it for a month.
And I just felt so good.
I was like,
well and you've been on it for,
so I started last December,
so a year.
Wow.
So a whole eat you whole year of just
eating meat cause you gotta do some
blood work,
man.
Well I probably will.
I mean,
you know,
but the point is,
I'm looking at the point I'm making is,
well what is it going to tell me?
Here's the thing,
we don't know.
One of the things is,
you know,
I'll tell you a little probably,
cause I've seen hundreds of hundreds of
people who've already done blood work.
So I know what it's going to show
basically.
You know.
So I've gotten,
we've got this study going,
we've got all these people to submitting
blood work.
But the,
uh,
you know,
probably my hdl will go out and my
triglycerides will go down.
My blood sugar stabilized to a low level
by my,
uh,
inflammatory markers will be normal does
because I've seen lots and lots of other
people's blood work already.
So I know it's going to show my
cholesterol may be up or down.
And that's the,
and that's something that we had a lot
of people worried about that.
And I can talk about cholesterol and my
view is a pretty worthless marker,
you know,
by itself.
You know,
you have to take it into context.
And so there's a,
you know,
there's a couple people that are really,
really intelligent about cholesterol
that it really testing this source of,
one guy's name is Dave Feldman on
twitter.
His name is Dave Kido.
There's another guy named Ivor Cummins,
who's an Australian thinks both
engineers.
And so this was,
this is what happened.
This guy date,
he goes on a ketogenic diet.
He was cholesterol goes sky frigging
heights,
like 400 you know,
way,
way up there.
And his doctor is freaking out and he's
freaking out.
So he's like,
I don't understand this.
I mean I feel great.
Everything about me is just best health
ever felt my life.
So what he does is he starts drawing his
blood every single day.
He gets a blood test and what he finds
out is that his blood cholesterol is all
over the place.
One day it's 300 and next day it's 201
days,
three 50 in the next day.
And so what we,
when we go to the doctor every six
months or a year and they get a blood
cholesterol uson and well that's my
cholesterol.
And it's always that way.
Well he found out that it's so variable.
They've actually known about this since
the 1950s but no one has been talking
about.
So what he figured out,
and he's a systems engineer and he's
engineered.
There's some smart guys.
I mean that's the one thing I,
I kind of talk about it,
just to get somebody as an md or phd
doesn't mean they know everything.
There's a lot of people that are
plumbers and whatever,
they don't have any formal training that
configure.
They're smart people and they can figure
this stuff out.
So he's in his,
he's an engineer,
real smart guy.
And so what he does,
he figures out the cholesterol is
basically all it is,
is it's traveling around in your blood
based on energy flux.
So how much,
so if you've eaten a lot,
so if you've eaten a whole bunch of food
and your fault,
your liver is saying,
I don't need to put out a bunch fat
cause you to burn fat as fuel and oil,
even if we're not in a kitty Jane died.
So what it does is it transports fat.
So when you're hungry,
you haven't eaten for a while.
Like you fasted for a blood test,
your liver says we need fat and misses
because we're low on energy.
And so it shoots out all this fat.
And what happens is cholesterol is
cruising around for a ride.
So it's just sitting there,
you know,
um,
as a passenger.
So depending on how much you eat and
when you've eaten,
it'll change your cholesterol.
And so it's not a very good marker.
I mean you can,
you can find studies that show for all
cause mortality.
Like if you're like you,
you and me on it,
cause you're,
you're the same age as I am.
I think you do it right.
Yeah.
We're both these.
So if we look at,
you know,
and again,
associational studies are not that
great,
but if you look at that and you say all
cause mortality,
if I'm,
am I going to die or not?
If your cholesterol is high,
you're less likely to die.
you're less likely to get Parkinson's
disease.
If your cholesterol is high,
you're less likely to get a bunch of
cancers.
You know,
so it's like,
see you saying that though,
but most people hear this and they go,
Bubba,
bubba.
If you have a cholesterol is high,
you got to get a heart attack.
Well,
here's the deal with the dye.
Yeah.
Here's what,
here's the deal of heart attack.
So,
and this is interesting because you
know,
vegetarian to Vegan,
I don't mean to pick on vegetarians
beings cause I know some great ones are
great people and I think,
you know,
there shouldn't be a war between us but
vegetarians and Vegans,
the number one killer of vegetarian
Vegan has heart disease.
I mean that's what kills him to,
it kills everybody.
So it's just like,
you know,
do you trade,
am I going to die of cancer?
Am I going to try it?
Die Of heart disease,
you know,
which,
which won't pick your poison.
Most people don't understand that the
sugar industry's hijacking of science in
the 1950s the way they paid off those
scientists to literally false advertise
the idea that sugar is safe for you,
but that saturated fat and cholesterol
is what's causing all of these issues
with people and heart attacks to this
day.
People just sort of repeat that.
Like they think it's Gospel.
Yeah.
I mean it's in,
it is,
it's part of the,
it's part of the framework of society
now.
I mean it's like,
it was the push that got you to say,
I'm just gonna eat nothing but meat.
Was there anybody that you knew that was
doing it really well that you were
talking to?
Did you get some where,
like I said,
it was just reading about people online,
you know,
um,
there's a,
you know,
if there's a,
I'll tell you what,
if there's a guy named Joe Anderson on
twitter,
his handle is Joe Charlene 98 eight 88
98 or 98.
It's this guy,
you know,
it's just the guy.
He's been doing it for 20 years.
I'm just like,
this is pretty cool.
Like I said,
reading back on that stuff and then just
because I've been an athlete and I'm
like,
and I don't,
you know,
I've never taken drugs and stuff like
that and I was always like,
what can get me to the next level as far
as athletic complex cause I'm just a
really competitive guy.
I mean,
I just,
I just like to,
you know,
push myself and see what works.
I know a lot of savage people that eat
mostly meet my friend Cam hands.
It's almost all meat.
Yeah.
He occasionally eats like something
else,
but most of what he eats is meat.
My friend Jocko willink.
Yeah.
When he's tired he goes,
I need more steak.
He eats a neat,
I mean it's a,
it's a fricking health food.
I totally is.
I mean,
and you know there's a guy named bobby
maximus who's a,
who's a fitness guy.
He was,
he,
I guess he was used to be an mma guy
years ago or something like that.
But I know he did this steak every day
thing.
And so if we look back into,
into history,
I mean there's all kinds of accounts of
people using meat as an athletic
performance enhancer.
You know,
back in the original Greek Olympics,
those guys knew that they had a lot of
meat to perform better.
You know,
the feeders out of London,
you know,
these guys with the guards for the
kings,
you know,
they gave them extra meat,
cause I know they would fight better.
The,
you know,
the Mongols,
they just decimated,
you know,
all through Asia.
They basically just ate their horses and
their meat.
That's what they did.
And I traveled with that,
you know,
and so you've got all these historical
examples of people performing better,
you know,
of what they were.
Laborers,
they were known to have this incredible
work capacity and all that.
You know,
all they was seal maiden and reindeer
and you know,
stuff like that.
So what's a typical diet for you?
Give me a normal day.
You wake up in the morning,
so I do,
well I'll tell you what to do it.
So today,
I mean,
you know,
eating wise,
some that,
you know,
general,
either one meal or two meals depending
on what my workout training's going to
be.
So this morning,
you know,
cause I knew I was coming up here.
I train early,
early morning.
Well it's fast.
You know,
I set a new record,
by the way,
in my personal record is doing that,
but I had a couple of New York strips,
so I had about two pounds,
two pounds of meat.
Well,
that's a snack,
ma'am.
Is that your phone man?
That keeps it keeping.
Might be,
might have your little thing on that.
I think I'll probably get notifications
from people saying,
hey bro,
you too,
Andrew,
let me turn it said,
man,
you look just like you.
So you had to New York strips today.
Yeah,
I mean that's,
you know,
pounds of meat.
You know,
it took me a while to build up to this
before,
you know,
like a pound of meat would be,
that'd be tough.
No,
I can,
I can put down four pounds at one time
with the people looking at you would go,
well,
he's the super lean.
Like obviously whatever you're eating,
your body's processing it really well
when you don't have a,
you don't have what someone would think
of as a steak eater.
Gut.
Like you tell a guy,
someone,
a guy eats two steaks a day and like,
oh,
it must have a gut.
That's how that mashed potatoes,
macaroni and cheese and stuff eat with
it.
I mean,
you know,
I've just,
uh,
you know,
I put,
like I said on that instagram page,
I've got,
you know,
me exercising and doing stuff and you
know,
pictures and that was something that you
talked about,
uh,
outside of the studio right before we
came in that the studies that have been
done on people consuming meat,
and I brought this up as well,
that there's a lot of misconceptions
about the studies because they're not
very clear when they say that people who
eat meat five times a week are more
likely to get cancer.
What they're not telling you is what
these people eight along with the meat,
are they eating cheeseburgers or the
eating grass fed beef or it's grass
finished,
grass fed,
you know,
high in essential fatty acids healthy
for you.
Or are they eating some bullshit
cheeseburger with a sugary drink?
Like what is the rest of their diet?
Are they consuming a lot of refined
carbohydrates?
Are they consuming a lot of sugar?
Are they drinking alcohol?
They smoking cigarettes.
All you're saying is they're eating meat
five days a week.
It's not,
it's not specifying in any way their
actual overall diet.
You know,
they don't,
they don't sort that very,
very well out.
So they've got all these epidemiology
studies in basically a mediator is
basically someone and,
and you know,
we statistically,
we know they're more likely to smoke,
they're more likely to drink.
They're more likely not to wear their
seatbelt.
They're more likely to be an accidents
are more likely not to go to their
doctor.
They're not,
they're more likely to just not to care.
So you've got,
that's what it means.
Why is that?
What's this cause people,
cause if I tell you,
as I say,
Joe eating meat's bad for you and you
say F you,
I don't care.
I don't care about my health.
Right,
right.
So you just don't care.
So is it,
so they can't
separate that out.
So they've got all these studies where
they,
they try to separate out and say well
what Kinda what Kinda even up to smokers
but they never can take that.
I don't give a,
you know,
I don't,
I don't give a fuck right thing out of
it.
So you've got this stuff and then all
the studies are really,
really low strength.
So if we look at w you know,
and we can talk about this about meat,
meat,
meat being causing cancer.
Cause there was,
there's some concern about that with
colon cancer.
But if we look at smoking,
you know when they determine that
smoking causes cancer,
the epidemiology showed a 2000% increase
in the incidence of cancer.
And a lot of studies when they compare
that to meat and cancer,
they found an 18% increase,
which is nothing.
I mean it's like,
it's like it doesn't even matter.
It's so percent isn't high,
not not when you look at relative risk,
right?
So if your risk,
if your risk of getting colon cancer is
one or say your,
your risk of getting colon cancer is a
five in a million.
Right?
And now it's six in a million.
I mean it's like nothing.
I mean it dislike it,
it's so minor.
But if your risk is going from five and
a million to 300 and a million,
then you're like,
well that's pretty powerful.
So it depends on the incident.
So if it's really low to begin with and
you only raise it but tiny mountain,
it's so small.
And so what we know there was a guy
named Bradford Hill who talked about
statistical correlations on when this
things actually matter and not to,
you get to 200% or 300% does it even
matter?
You can't draw any conclusion from that.
The problem is 200 300% difference out
of like a thousand yeah.
So sort of two,
it would be six [inaudible],
right?
So instead of,
right.
So instead of being 18% more like a
year,
200% more likely that those numbers are
confusing to people though the way he's
saying 200% like what?
That's a lot of people,
right?
So,
so you would have to double or triple
your risk.
So 18% is not double or tripling.
That's only putting it up by it,
by a fraction.
Right?
Right.
So when you,
when you separate all that stuff out and
then,
then you know,
there was,
uh,
you know,
the World Health Organization two years
ago,
last year,
two years ago,
declared that red meat wasn't class two
carcinogen.
Prosec meets was a class one carcinogen.
You know,
they said it's like plutonium and
smoking and you know,
everybody runs to runs all over the
place with that.
Why'd they do that?
So here's why they do that.
So first of all,
and you can read,
you can go on their website,
you know,
they'll tell you what their,
what their conclusions were.
So this was done by an organization
called the International Association for
Research on cancer.
They're based on a Leland France and
they are,
uh,
you know,
that's what the World Health
Organization uses to determine their
stuff.
And so there are written,
and this is,
you know,
besides appointment right now the IRC is
under,
under investigation by the US Congress
for using crappy science and you know,
promoting political agenda.
So I don't know if that's true or not.
Part of that's generated by the probably
be corporations.
You don't like their findings,
but so they're under investigation for
that.
But what they say is we have some weak
epidemiology,
which is 18% stuff,
but we think we have some strong
mechanistic reasons for this.
Right?
So if everybody,
you know there's isn't,
there's a doctor named George Ead Ede
who's a,
who's a psychiatrist out in Maryland
who's got this,
this tremendous,
she analyzed the whole thing.
She has a website called diagnosis
diet.com so she did an analyst analysis
of all the 800 studies they used and she
found that what they ended up doing is
most of them showed me,
didn't cause cancer.
There was a small percentage it did.
And they looked at all these rat studies
and there was about 20 2025 rat studies.
And they found like three or four of
them showed meat.
You know,
if we gave this type of cancer,
if we gave this rat a certain,
you know,
amount of meat and we genetically bred
them and we gave them a ma,
a medicine that makes them get cancer,
that they get a little bit of change in
their colon that might turn into cancer
medicine that makes them get cancer.
Well I don't remember.
It's something there.
There's a special way to make get
cancer.
So they have this model that it makes
them get cancer really,
really easy.
So what they did is they felt,
why did they do that?
If we're trying to find out if something
gives something cancer.
Well because they want to make it,
they want to be able to,
you know,
they want to differentiate that as quick
as possible because they've got to use a
million rats.
And I see,
I see what you're saying is the real
fast way to show up.
They get cancer.
But the problem with that,
and she explains it very well,
is that we don't know that they would
get cancer.
It's,
and it's not shown.
And the other thing we talked about this
before is that if you want to look at a
rat studies,
and it's not to say that plants give you
cancer,
but there are pesticides and plants that
have been studying rats that we eat
every day.
Natural foods and vegetables and fruits
that also give racks cancer and so the
only difference is we've got,
you know,
submitted some really,
you mean things that natural compounds
that plants extract or they write
secreted in order,
does it discourage predation?
Exactly.
These natural substances,
when they feed them to rats and the
isolate them and feed them to rats,
it gives the rads cancer at 52 they kept
tested.
27 of them is just normal food that we
eat on [inaudible] stuff we do on a
daily basis.
So it's not to scare people out of
eating that stuff,
but it's just saying that's how much bs
and stuff is based upon.
It just seems to me to be so crazy that
they would,
the,
they're doing a cancer study and they
give the rat something that induces
cancer in order to find out what gives
him cancer more.
So they give them this compound and on
top of the compound and they,
they check their diet.
Right.
And they also feed them sugar with it,
you know?
So it's Kinda like,
it's just the way they do it,
you know,
and you know,
you can,
you can extrapolate.
Does that really matter to humans or
not?
It's just so hard to tell.
I mean,
there's so many things that animals can
eat that we can't.
It just,
the whole thing is bizarre.
Yeah.
I mean,
we're not rats,
you know?
That's interesting.
You know,
it's like the same thing when we talked
about,
you know,
cancer rates in the historical
populations,
you know,
what Messiah,
they didn't,
they didn't have much cancer,
you know,
not until we started feeding them,
the 1940 stories and stuff like that.
Nothing.
So til we started feeding him all our
crap that they,
that they started to get those diseases.
Yeah.
That's,
uh,
it's all very strange,
right.
When you think about diet and health,
you also have to take into account
geographically,
uh,
the,
the geography that your ancestors
evolved in and what did they,
what were they accustomed to eating?
Like there's different adaptations for
the nun.
For example,
adaptations to cold.
They probably have requirements for
certain amount of dietary fat.
Yeah,
I think it's,
you know,
this is what I think is,
I think we're all,
you know,
this is one of the things that people
talked about their so like,
you know,
everybody is so different.
We have all this different genetics.
We need special diets.
I tend to say that,
you know,
in certain circumstances that make
sense.
But I think,
you know,
evolutionary,
we,
we sort of split from primates.
You know,
we,
we shared a common ancestor with
primates,
chimpanzees,
Bonobos,
gorillas somewhere eight to 10 million
years ago.
We don't know for sure.
It was back and then,
and so what happens is,
you know,
the human,
the pre humans kind of went one way and
then the apes and chimpanzees went up to
swim when we went up into the trees.
And if you look at,
you know,
even the difference between a chimpanzee
in a,
in an ape,
an ape or not an ape,
a gorilla,
gorilla crushes all these,
you know,
these all really fibers,
food,
lots of fiber and stuff like that.
Chimpanzees can't tolerate that as well
because they're there.
They're colon,
got a little smaller,
will humans.
Colin's got way,
way smaller,
right?
And so what happened is why you and I
can throw a rock really far.
You don't,
a chimpanzee chimpanzee can throw,
you know,
if you give a Cimzia baseball,
they can throw in about 20 miles an
hour.
It's not very strong.
You and I can throw a baseball,
you know,
60 miles an hour average guy,
if you get,
you know,
major league baseball players are
throwing at 95 plus,
right?
The reason we evolve to do that is
because we're throwing shit in animals.
We were hunting.
Right.
That's what drove,
I mean,
our scapula has rotated,
you know,
tim,
if you'll get a chimpanzee Scapula,
it's,
you know,
on the side,
it allows him to crump,
climb trees and do this stuff.
And so these strong climate based
evolutionary pressures,
which drove us to saying,
you know,
there's,
there's all this ice age stuff going on.
The,
the,
the climate's drawing out the fruits and
the jungles are going away.
Now it's all this grassland and you
know,
there's not much eat in the grassland,
you know,
except for some animals,
people need some bugs and stuff like
that for awhile.
And that's what,
you know,
chimpanzees or even chimpanzees,
3% of their diet.
You know,
there's a lot of people say we're
frugivores and always should be.
It's fruit.
But even chimpanzees eat about 3% of
their diet comes from killing other
animals.
I mean,
yeah,
there's this red colobus monkey
somewhere and you can hand it or
somewhere in Africa,
the chimpanzees are hunting,
listening to extinction.
The,
they're,
they're good little hunters.
But
yeah,
there's a David attenborough documentary
on it.
It's terrifying.
And you see how organized they are to
kill monkeys.
They have chimps at one end of this tree
line and they're coming this way and
they have chips on the side and they
chase him in and then they,
they corner him,
they ambush them and they get them in
the center and they just swarm them.
That's amazing.
I mean,
and you know,
think about it.
Their brain is not even half as big as
ours.
I mean,
so when humans sort of,
no,
I think that's,
I think it's pretty clear that what
drove a lot of our evolution,
evolution,
our ability to communicate,
to strategize.
You know,
some of the anatomic things was based
around hunting.
I mean,
hunting,
I know you're a hunter Geo,
and I know it's,
it's not an easy thing to do.
You've got to think a lot.
You know,
you've got to be pretty smart.
Dot Smart.
These animals I'm supposed to be when
you're in big groups and been back then
when they've got,
you know,
I got it.
Spears basically,
you know,
you look at a,
there was a population in central Europe
called the Gravettian is right.
So if you look at population markers for
nutrition,
right?
The,
uh,
one of the things I look at is
population height.
So if there's a real top height tall
population,
it means that they had really good
nutrition.
And so if you look at the tallest people
that probably ever live where these
gravette that teams,
these guys were just decimating
mammoths.
I mean,
they were so efficient at killing
mammoths.
And so that's probably basically all
they ate.
You know,
for the most part,
they might have a little vegetables,
but they are,
they were there advertise it was like
six foot two.
And this is like 30,000 years ago.
That's crazy.
So these things have been giant.
They were giants.
And so the people that have did,
have sort of genetically are related to
those people now are the people from
Croatia and the Netherlands were turning
in the tallest people in the world.
The only other group that rivaled that
are the neurotic,
uh,
Africans,
which are like the,
what to see in the Messiah,
which are all about six feet tall and
average.
And their diet is primarily as we know,
livestock based.
And then the other tall population
historically were the plains Indian,
particularly in the Cheyenne Injury
Indians and they just lived on mostly
buffalo.
So it's kind of,
it's kind of interesting as far as
what's the best food for nutrition,
you know,
and uh,
that's what I'm finding from a
performance standpoint,
you know,
it's just will make me feel the best and
work the best.
Do you supplement,
do you take vitamins or minerals or
anything?
You know,
I don't,
you know what,
I just,
you know,
I,
I kind of,
you know,
just,
I mean,
well I will say I take some salt,
salt,
my meat,
you know,
I mean,
I'll have some Himalayan salt or some
regular sauna.
How do you normally cook?
You Cook for yourself also time and you
get pretty good at cooking steaks.
You haven't,
so I'll either reverse here,
you know,
you know how to,
you know how to reverse sear here,
reverse sear a steak in a cast and cook
it slowly,
slowly low heat to talk to internal
temperature.
I do,
I just like,
but medium rare and then a throw in a
pan for a couple minutes and sear it up
and they need it or I'll just throw it
on the grill.
You know,
it depends where I'm,
where I'm at.
If from California,
I got a grill,
Harish,
I'll throw one in the grill.
If I'm back,
you know,
in another,
in New Mexico,
I'll,
I'll just,
I'll do it to come and have a girl
there.
So I do that.
But that's that,
you know,
it takes a,
a couple of minutes to do a lot of
supermarket runs cause that get
expensive.
It's gotta be an expensive diet and
yeah.
So I mean it's,
you know,
it depends,
it depends on,
you know,
again,
how much I'm probably eating more than
the average person that does this diet
that I'm aware of.
She only goes about two pounds,
two pounds of meat.
And so they can do day a day.
Right.
And so a lot of people,
you know,
people that are,
that are,
uh,
you know,
don't have the budget of the stupid like
ground beef and stuff like that.
And you can do,
you can eat two pounds of ground beef
for,
you know,
under 10 bucks a day,
which is right.
Wait,
you know,
it's two cups of starbucks,
something like that.
So it's actually not that bad for a lot
of people.
Now there's also people that have
ethical concerns about the consumption
of animals,
especially the consumption of factory
farmed animals.
Sir,
on a mass basis.
I mean,
you're probably responsible for a whole
goddamn feel.
Dead Cows.
Yeah.
So I mean,
I think,
I mean,
I think I have a concern.
I think people that eat meat should be
concerned about,
and we're the ones that primarily need
to make sure that's not happening.
And so I think,
you know,
as you know,
I would argue that,
you know,
since evolution began,
humans have been eating meat and that's
just what happens in nature.
You know,
if you look at how an animal's killing a
wild,
if Elian takes down under zebra,
it's not a pleasant experience for that
animal.
And so most of the way that humans kill
these animals now,
you know,
from it from a humane say,
it's pretty darn humane.
I mean,
even as a hunter,
you know,
if you hit an animal and you don't get
them,
you know,
you don't hit on the right spot,
you got to track him down and he's going
to,
it may take an hour or longer.
So the issue is not necessarily even
just the eventual death of the animal,
it's also the life of the animal was
killed.
Yeah,
I agree with that too.
And so I think that,
uh,
you know,
you have to look at,
um,
you know,
if the animals,
like if you've got chickens in cages and
they can't turn around right,
and they're just as cramped in there,
that's awful.
No,
it shouldn't be allowed.
One of the reasons they put chicken in
case cause they'll peck the hell out of
each other.
You know,
if they don't say anything they'll just
tear each other up.
So that,
you know,
there are different considerations on
that.
You know,
if you have an animal that you're,
you know,
cause I talked to a lot of cattle
ranchers and most of them,
I mean most of them they really care
about their animals are out in the snow
and the rain,
making sure their animals are fed,
making sure they're sheltered.
You know,
if an animal goes down there taking care
of that.
So,
you know,
there's probably some bad apples out
there and if we know about that stuff
and some Vegan documentary guy wants to
make a film about that,
then yeah,
those guys should be saying,
hey don't mistreat your animals.
You know,
don't,
you know,
intentionally hurt them.
Don't have them standing in a pilot
crap.
You know,
give them some,
you know,
fresh air and some,
some ability to move.
But you know,
you know,
if you look cows or animals in the wild,
they're herd animals anyway.
So they hang out together anyway.
It's not like if they're indoors now,
if they're indoors and they've got no
room to move around and they go in and
go out,
I think that'll,
I think that's a big issue.
And so I think you have to kind of,
you know,
you can't just make it all black and
white.
There's some people that are good at it.
Some people are bad.
The bad ones need to be made not to do
that anymore.
But it doesn't change the fact that we
all need to eat.
There's a company called butcher box
that'll sell you a grass fed grass
finished beef too.
They send it to you.
They're one of the sponsors of the show.
And,
uh,
I've,
I've eaten there meat.
It's very good.
And if you're a certain,
if you're in a place and we have it,
like,
uh,
isn't there like some sort of like a,
like a password or something that we
give them to see what could find that?
But,
um,
there's,
there's ways to get,
I mean you have to search for it though.
It's not meat that you get.
You don't really exactly know how the
person is raising it.
It's,
it's hard.
I mean if you can go,
unless you go to a,
some sort of a farmer's market or
something like that,
okay.
You can get $10 off plus free bacon by
using the code word Rogan and butcher
box.com.
So butcher box is one option.
There's a,
I'm sure there's,
like I said,
farmers markets are great too.
You can actually meet the ranchers and
uh,
you know,
get a sense of how they raise these
animals.
But I think for health wise it's really
critical to get grass fed grass raised
to get the best.
Did you pay attention to that or do you
just take whatever you can get?
Yeah,
so I think,
I think,
you know,
I think you're right in the fact that if
you say,
what is the most nutrient dense,
what is the best quality I can get grass
fed grass finished is going to fill that
bill.
Now,
if you compare that to something that
was,
you know,
fed corn,
right?
And given hormones and given antibiotics
and what else did I do?
You know,
so you know,
you've got those things and it's fed no
grain the difference nutritionally
compared to,
you know,
cause if you don't have any money and
you can't afford the stuff compared to
the rest of the crap and the supermarket
is,
you know,
so,
so I'll use it,
I'll use a mma analogy for you.
So have grass fed,
grain fed beef is,
you know,
conor Mcgregor or GSP,
right?
Then there's other stuff is say some guy
who's like the number three contenders
or something like that,
that close the differences.
And you know,
because you look at hormones and beat,
you know,
so,
so you don't want any hormones in your
media,
right?
Right.
You don't want antibiotics in your
media,
the right,
so you're in your grass fed beef,
even the Lq kill,
you've got hormones in that stuff
because the animal makes it natural
course.
So you're getting a ventral horn hard
getting on very low level.
And so what they do is they give those
animals generally the same hormones.
It didn't increase as a percentage,
a little bit more compared to what you
and I make normally.
So if they,
if we look at like grants,
you know what maybe,
you know,
I can't remember the numbers exactly,
but the scale is what's important.
So if they give you,
if grass fed beef gives you five Nanning
rams of estrogen,
okay,
grain fed beef gives you 10 nanograms of
estrogen and then you compare it to
eggs,
which give you maybe 90 and you compare
it to dairy,
which gives you 110 and then you compare
it to,
you know,
uh,
if you look at Fido estrogens,
you know,
that's,
that's in the millions,
right?
So,
so things like soy beans and stuff like
that,
and then you compare it to what is your
body naturally make?
And that's like 30 or 40,000.
And so it's a really small level.
So I think if you can afford grass fed
and grain fed,
you know,
I'm,
I'm not saying how can you solve the
world's problem?
And I think if you're just telling,
if we just isolate for health only,
so you're a poor guy and all you can
afford is,
you know,
I can't afford his grasp and mean I
can't for 20 bucks a pound for this
stuff,
right?
And butcher box is still too expensive
for me,
then that's probably still a better
option than going back and eating,
you know,
uh,
the other crap,
the other car,
the cheetos and uh,
you know,
all this other stuff.
And even though you don't like the
organic fruits and stuff like that,
you know,
it's just expensive for people.
So,
I mean,
I think it's,
you know,
like I said,
it depends on who your audiences,
you know,
if you've got unlimited resources and
most people don't,
then you have to say what's,
you know,
what's,
from a health standpoint,
what is most affordable and what's
practical?
How do I get my health back?
Because this is,
you know,
I don't,
like I said,
I don't really,
I'm not like saying this is the best
diet in the world.
Everybody,
I'm just saying you need to find out
what works for you.
Right.
But basically what you're saying is that
grass fed beef is better,
but it's only slightly better for you.
Right?
I mean in the grand scheme of things,
right?
So if you're saying I want to be as good
as I possibly can be and that I said
probably grass fed,
grain fed and grass when it's probably
better if you're like saying I'm just
sick and I don't want to be sick
anymore,
then I'd say get what you can afford.
So you really think that meat is in some
ways a panacea for health.
You think that it really,
if you just eat more meat that your body
will be what?
More vibrant and more healthy and like
what is,
what is it about meat specifically?
Well I think it's,
you know,
so this is another sort of
misconception.
So I think a lot of it's extremely well
absorbed in our body.
I mean it's look at the end result of
why we,
what do we do when we,
when we're eating.
Okay.
What's the end result?
We eat for two reasons.
We ill eat to get energy and to build an
animal tissue.
I mean you and I are animals or animal
tissue.
The most efficient way to do that is
just eatsa because your body has,
it has,
it says everything in the,
in the proportions that we need it.
Right?
And it's,
you know,
it's a misconception.
You know,
when you hear,
a lot of people will say,
you know,
if he'd be a bunch of me just kind of
sit there and rot in your intestines and
it's going to putrefying and stuff like
that.
So they've done studies on people who
have had ileostomies and these are
people that have had their colon
removed,
right?
So you've had colon cancer,
inflammatory bowel disease,
like Crohn's disease where they take out
your whole colon and now you've got a
little back what you pooped until this
little bag,
right?
So they've looked at people and they've
looked at what comes out when they eat
meat.
Almost nothing comes out.
There's a little bit of liquid,
right?
So that means all that means is being
absorbed,
you know?
But when you get a bunch of fiber and
vegetables and plants,
all that stuff goes up in the back
because you can't digest it.
You got to have,
you have to have bacteria in your colon
to do that in humans are not really good
at it compared to other primates.
We're really bad at it.
What about probiotics?
So I think probiotics,
you know,
the microbiome is fascinating and
there's a lot of research going on.
There's a lot of people just talking all
about the stuff,
how it affects your health.
One of the things that we,
we try to say is how do we define a
healthy microbiome?
You can't yet.
We just don't know enough.
There are,
you know,
we can't even,
we don't even know everything about the
human body.
And then to put in tens of billions of
different bacteria,
whole different,
different species and say,
this is the perfect combination and
that's perfectly fine.
But we're so far away from knowing that
we're in the very infancy and what that
means.
So what I would say is if you are
healthy,
you know,
if your joints don't hurt,
if everything's going good,
then probably by definition your
microbiome is fine.
If you're eating just a meat based diet,
your microbiome is going to be different
in the probiotics are probably not going
to make a difference for him.
But if you're eating,
if you're eating a crappy diet,
you know,
and you're fitting your,
your gut,
a bunch of sugar,
you're going to get this dysbiosis,
which is bad,
you know,
bad bacteria.
And then,
um,
you know,
maybe the private probiotics might help
in that situation.
I'm not convinced,
you know,
I just,
I just don't think there's a,
you know,
enough evidence to show that that's a
big deal.
That's interesting.
So you think that perhaps
maybe the probiotics exist or maybe the
probiotics are healthy?
It's my
freaking out.
Well,
audio levels.
Yeah.
Too loud.
No,
not long enough.
Let's talk.
So,
um,
so the probiotics you think maybe only
beneficial if people are consuming a lot
of variable things are a very diet,
like carbohydrates,
all sorts of different things.
And then maybe the co,
the probiotics are necessary to sort of
balance you out.
Is that what you're thinking?
I mean,
that potentially could be the case.
So you think that the microbiome of
someone who eats meat is probably
designed to eat meat?
Well,
it is.
I mean,
I,
your,
your microbiome reacts to whatever you
do,
how much sleep you get,
how much exercise you do,
how much you eat,
how much stress is in your life.
This is very,
very adaptable.
It can change in a day,
right?
You know,
so whatever you're feeding it
chronically is going to change.
What wouldn't,
what bacteria live there.
So,
you know,
it's like this thing about,
again,
back to this meet putrefaction thing.
So if we look at the definition of
putrefaction here,
sounds awful,
right?
It's putrefying,
Putrefaction is the activity of bacteria
on protein,
right?
So protein getting your colon,
it'll pewter fry,
right?
So again,
when we go back to these ileostomies
patients,
they studied people that were getting
soy,
protein and meat,
and guess which one had more protein
going into the colon?
Soy Protein.
So meeting and what to soit means stuff
means more proteins going into your
colon and your getting it more future
facts in that way.
Is that rumor,
like I know very little about what soy
supposed to do to you in terms of like
raising your estrogen levels.
Is that supposed to be a real thing?
Well,
I mean there's a lot of people think so.
I mean there's some studies that support
that.
I don't know for sure.
I mean,
I don't,
I don't think soy is a particularly good
food for us.
I know some people will say that
fermented soy,
you know,
it is a little better.
Yeah,
heard that's good for you actually
write,
what does that called?
Not to,
not only not,
I think it's an Asian type thing,
but you know,
I think that there's certainly some
people that think there's a lot of
associations that guys getting
Gynecomastia and stuff like that from
eating too much.
Guys really done that.
I feel like that's one of those things
where people just tell you,
hey man,
you're gonna get bitch too.
Them.
I,
you know,
I've got no idea.
I honestly guys getting that from
anything other than steroids.
I mean,
they're,
they're supposedly are.
I don't know for sure.
I can't say.
I can't say for sure.
Okay.
Yeah.
Um,
so now that you've been doing this,
do you plan on,
you've done it for a year now,
do you plan on continuing this for life?
Is this your diet now or are you going
to mix it up a little like,
right.
So I'm going to,
you know,
I seriously doubt I will not eat a ton
of meat.
You know,
I just think I feel too good.
I mean,
I think I want to feel good and perform
as good as I can for as long as I can.
So whether I say,
and this is what I tell people,
you know,
do it for a couple months,
because this is one of the problems,
so many people that have health
problems,
and I think a lot of it's food related
and it's really hard to sort that out.
You know,
if you're eating a hundred different
types of food,
which one is it?
I don't know.
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna drop this out.
Right.
So,
and it's obviously variable in terms of
your own individual biology.
Right?
Right.
So,
but I mean,
when you dropped down to just meet then
it's pretty easy.
You just say,
okay,
I'm only meeting now if I add fruit back
hand,
does that f me up or not?
You know,
if it does and I'm like,
man,
I shouldn't probably eat that if I eat
dairy backhand.
So probably there'll be a point when
I'll say,
hey,
I'm going to,
you know,
I mean,
maybe once in a while I have a,
you know,
have some berries again,
and then to see how I do with that.
I mean there's nothing wrong with that.
There are a lot of people,
I'll tell you that these guys have been
doing it for five,
eight,
10 15 years.
I mean,
they're like,
man,
that stuff to have screws me up and I
don't want to do that.
Who was the guy that you were saying?
Did you find that gentleman online?
Young,
jammy.
The uh,
did you get the tab?
I had a few people up,
but I've pulled him off.
Which one?
The guy that he was saying,
oh,
Anderson,
Joey.
And I couldn't find him.
It was a,
can you,
if you go out,
if you go on my instagram,
there's about,
I don't know,
about a month or two ago,
I've got a picture I put up for these
people.
These are all people that have done it
for a total of 55 years.
Okay.
And there's one guy,
he's a marathon runner.
Uh,
and then these other two couples that
have been doing it for 20 years and
other Gal,
there's nothing galleries was Kelly
Hogan and that,
uh,
she was like big morbidly obese woman
and she went on a conversation,
she's not for eight years and she got
super lean.
Uh,
she was to totally in fertile,
couldn't have kids,
right?
Super Lean carnivores.
Dot.
Three kids later,
happy as can be.
All she does is eat hamburgers every
day.
I mean,
that's,
I mean it's,
it's,
you know,
the stories I get,
this is because now I'm this kind of
central point and I get all these crazy,
crazy stories of people just,
just from talking about it online,
just from talking.
Yeah.
It's kind of like sending,
is that?
Well,
it's kind of like a little movement,
I think.
And I think what you'll see over the
next year or two,
there's going to be a lot more people
doing this just to try it.
You know?
And I think it's,
you know,
it's a crazy,
some people are going to do it just to
say,
hey,
it's cool.
I'm going to be a carnivore.
I'm just gonna.
I'm going to screw around.
But I think there's people that honestly
are doing it and they're really
seriously improving their health.
And I think whatever works is what you
should do.
Well,
I think that the removal of refined
carbohydrates almost helps everybody.
No,
I agree.
100% done.
If not the removal,
the severe restriction,
just restrict most car.
I mean,
I think a day a week just have at it,
have a fucking slice of pizza who gives
a shit go to town.
I don't think there's anything wrong
with a cheat day,
but I think overall refined
carbohydrates just do not seem to be a
healthy nor normal thing for your body
to consume.
Well,
if we look at,
you know,
historically,
I mean,
you know,
we didn't start consuming dairy and all
about 12,000 years going to start
farming until about the same time.
So those things aren't in living novel.
You know,
we didn't start eating all this
processed stuff all about a hundred you
know,
Chris Cole came on in 1910 or something
like it's all that crap we've invented
in the last century.
And then when the high fructose corn
syrup came in in the 70s all this stuff
our human body just hasn't evolved for
yet.
So I think we're getting,
we're getting seriously messed up.
Yeah.
And if you look at the change in our
diet,
there's a corresponding uptick and
diabetes and all sorts of other obesity
and health
issues,
sugar and refined carbohydrates tills.
The two big ones.
There were,
the other debate is whether or not
eating all this meat is healthy for you.
And what about diverticulitis?
Have you ever heard about people getting
that?
Cause I know a d that's what brock
lesnar got.
And one of the things that they said
that he got it from just eating mostly
meat.
Yeah.
This is interesting because there's
actually a gunny,
pier e p e r r y did a study in 2014 he
did colonoscopies,
right?
So he actually looked at people who was
one of the first ones to do this and he
looked at people on these diets and he
found that the people that ate the
highest amount of fiber and had the most
bowel movements had the most incidents
of diverticulosis.
So diverticulosis proceeds
diverticulitis.
So diverticulosis,
a little pouch that shoots out from your
colon.
So it's like a little sack.
So what happens is that eventually gets
infected and then you get diverticulitis
with the people that were developing
diverticulosis and most in his study,
he did two or three like this show,
the ones that are reading a bunch of
fiber.
And there's also studies on so that
fiber gets caught or somethings that
potentially,
so the question is one of the thing
people don't understand,
you know,
cause a lot of people want to talk about
ketogenic diets.
They cut out their fiber,
they're like,
you're gonna get all constipated,
right?
I mean,
you know,
so basically I haven't had a bowel
movement in a year.
You know,
it's got Ya.
That's not true obviously.
But so what happens is you just don't
make anything.
I mean you,
you know all that meat,
it goes right into your small
intestines.
It's absorbs from next to nothing.
It gets to your colon.
And so it takes,
yeah,
there's nothing,
there's hardly anything.
You can take a little tiny coops.
Exactly.
What if you're like one of those dudes
that's backed up,
you don't even realize it.
And you got like 20 pounds of on
digestive.
Is that the always the funny,
yeah.
That's the thing that I like John Wayne
and stuff like that.
But what happens is,
what was the story?
Oh well he died with a colon full of
stuff,
but they said it'd be bowling ball.
Well,
but I mean,
who knows?
It's probably what it was.
It wasn't me.
You know,
look,
look at this Joe.
If you go to the bathroom and you'd a
bunch of corn,
he looked down in there.
Sometimes there's some corn floating
around.
When's the last time times.
Almost every time.
When's the last time you saw a piece of
steak floating around in the toilet bone
to bone that may have your eaten bombs
but meet this doesn't get there.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's a total myth.
And so when we talk about what causes
constipation is probably a neurologic
thing.
It's probably a neuromuscular thinks the
colon is not correct contracting
correctly.
It may have to do with electrolyte
deficiency.
It certainly varies depending on my
diet.
When I eat a lot of vegetables,
man,
it just comes flying out like,
well it's because you just put more in
the right,
so you're not constipated,
you're just,
you're just putting your stuff and
you're just shoveling more stuff
through.
The tube is sort of,
but it seems like it comes out quicker.
Like when I drink.
The craziest thing for sure for me is
Kale shakes.
When I drink Kale shakes.
Woo.
Hang on,
Hannah.
Where are you getting about your,
I mean,
you're getting a bunch of,
you know,
liquid fibers getting into your colon a
lot quick,
cleans it all out.
It makes it feel good though.
It may be,
you know,
there's some people that do it,
but there's no real prize for the most.
But when you,
at the end of your life,
you're not going to get an award for
more having more bowel moments.
You don't,
you don't,
you don't shit.
Yeah,
I,
you sure?
Well,
I'm not 100% sure of,
but I'm not,
I'm not aware of so,
but that side too again.
Um,
but most people think that just in all
seriousness,
start seriousness that,
that uh,
consuming fiber is important for like
bowel movements and you overall
intestinal health and all that stuff.
Yeah.
There's no doubt.
The more fiber you eat,
the more battles you're going to have.
But what happens if you,
if you get constipated,
and there's another study about this,
he looked at people with chronic
constipation that were always
constipated and the only thing that
helped them was taking all fiber in
their diet,
grilling and then there's a study.
Uh,
but that's crazy because that's what
people like mute.
What does that music is still,
what does that stuff,
metamucil,
metamucil.
Isn't that like,
yeah,
it's fine.
Yeah,
but what happens is what you have is you
got a neuromuscular problem where the
colon is not contracting the right way
and so you're blacked up and then you
just shove more fiber in there and it
just fills up more and more and
eventually just come.
Maybe you might be the force it all
through,
but,
but that's not,
you know how that's,
you know,
it's,
a lot of people will say that.
I will tell you there was a lot of
people that will tell me fiber just
jacks up their intestines.
I mean,
they feel awful and they'd taken a lot
of fiber.
I have heard that before.
When people try five or supplements that
they have issues.
Now do you very due lamb occasionally or
wild game or,
yeah,
I mean,
depends what's available.
you know,
I'm pretty happy with,
with uh,
with beef,
but I mean,
when I was,
I was in France earlier this year and I
had just a bunch of lamb,
you know,
that's,
that's easier to get.
I'll have,
sometimes they'll have chicken,
you know,
having a game.
Meanwhile,
I wouldn't get any gaming since I've
started this,
but I used to,
I've eaten elka foreign deer and you
know,
Chili's and students,
stuff like that.
So that's,
that's fine.
But I mean,
but you don't necessarily eat a lot of
chicken hot.
It's mostly red meat.
Yeah.
I just find it,
I didn't,
there's a lot of people like me to do
this.
They just find chicken is not as
satisfying.
It's just,
it's probably not as nutritious,
you know?
It's just kind of like,
it doesn't feel as satisfying when
you're eating it.
Yeah,
no,
that's it.
It's probably not,
you know,
I think it's just harder to do that.
I'm always trying to figure out like
what is that response that you get when
you slice into a steak and it's juicy
and delicious and you're,
your whole body goes,
oh,
well I think that's,
you know,
I think that's a primitive thing that
goes back a hundred thousand years.
I mean,
that's like,
that's like the point of,
you know,
all it's hunting.
We did and it's just what,
what,
what kind of satisfies?
It's why I always try to explain to
people that the difference between like
domestic beef versus like a slice of
like Moose tenderloin,
like the difference in the richness of
the flavor and the darkness of the meat
and the,
the nutrition content of the food is so
much higher that the [inaudible] is
higher too.
Like the,
when you slice into and you're like,
oh my God,
it just,
your body's like that,
more of that.
There we go.
That's what we're looking at.
Media.
I think it's a primal thing.
I think it's just like,
this is satisfaction.
I know really is.
Well,
the Vegan army has a,
they've got their troops pointed in your
direction,
right?
I'm sure.
Yeah.
I mean,
I've got a bunch of tweets about you and
one of the,
one of the tweets was,
uh,
talking about your record as a doctor in
New Mexico and stuff that you and I went
back and forth.
Sure,
sure,
sure.
So let's,
let's like get that out and try to
figure out what the issue was.
Sure.
All right.
So,
so,
you know,
I was,
like I said,
I'll just go to it,
my background
a little bit.
So I,
you know,
I go to,
I go to medical school,
you know,
I go to a degree in biology,
then I go to medical school,
then I dropped out of medical school to
play professional rugby.
You know,
I had just kind of a crazy,
crazy career.
Then I go into the military and at
launch nuclear bombs for,
you know,
uh,
five years nuclear bombs.
Yeah.
That was a nuclear bomb launch officer
for about five years.
Where do you still launched nuclear
bombs?
Well,
I mean,
up in Wyoming and Nebraska and Colorado
and their taxi detonate them.
No,
no.
That's where there,
that's where you shoot them from
actually launch it.
But you will work out.
And I was the guy that if we went to war
and say Donald Trump says we want to
nuke North Korea out of and the guy goes
moon,
it's a button.
So I did that.
So you know,
they do all this crazy psychological
screening to make sure you're not some
psychopath,
you know,
so I'm just like straight ethical guide.
It's dislike,
you know,
you know a good,
just a good solid guy that's a top
secret clearance and all that stuff.
So I do all this stuff.
So then I go play rugby and then I get
tired of getting my head kicked in.
You know,
I was playing,
you know,
I remember my last match has plenty of
some Russian team I'm laying on the
ground and it just cannot tee it off on
my head.
Kicking me in the head.
I got blood's coming out of my ears and
I'm like,
I'm 30 years old.
I'm like F it,
I'm going to go back to medical school.
So,
so I go back to medical school with the
military pays for it this time.
So then,
you know,
I do my time and you know,
go through to go through school and my
training and graduate top,
you know right at the top of my class in
medical school because getting
orthopedics,
you gotta you gotta be like,
it's wanting to real competitive clc,
you gotta be really at the top of the
class to do that.
So I do that stuff,
do all my training,
bust my ass,
do really well,
get all these awards and train.
Then I get to in the military and then
they send me to war.
Right.
So they send me to Afghanistan and this
is,
if it's okay,
I'll give it to tell you a little bit
about it.
So I'm,
you know,
I come out of training,
not long was training and me and this
other dude,
his name's Tom Large.
Excellent,
excellent surgeon.
Good.
One of the,
just a great guy,
great people.
Me and him are the only two guys at the
main center in Afghanistan.
So you fly out there,
it takes you about three days.
You go to Bangor,
Maine,
and these old ladies give you lobster
bisque and away out.
It's kind of cool.
Then you fly to Turkey and then we sat
there for like six hours on a runway,
wouldn't let us move,
they wouldn't let us off the plane.
And then they fly into Kurdistan,
which is there used to be part of the
Soviet Union.
So Union.
So we've got a US base in what was
usually Soviet Union.
So we stayed there for one and it's
freezing cold.
And then we,
then we get on this c one 30 which is a
military plane.
You know,
you're packed in there with the cargo
and you fly in Afghanistan and they're
shooting at just,
they turn off the lights so that,
you know,
hopefully they don't hit you.
They're shooting at,
you should come in.
So we get in there and then I get off
the plane and they put you in this giant
hall with like 300 guys on cots first
night.
And then we go to the first day to go to
work.
Right.
And we're taking over from the army and
I was in the air force at the time.
So we're taking over for the arm.
And the first thing that rolls in and
there's poor,
I mean I remember this man,
it was,
it was like welcome to fucking war.
There was a guy,
Canadian guy who was 23 year old kid,
his special forces guy,
you know,
full beard.
Cause you know the special forces guys
would wear beards cause it was so they
could blend in,
right?
Both legs blown right off.
I mean look like Holy Shit.
You know.
So this is like,
this is stuff discount real.
So every day,
boom,
trunk.
Crazy train.
We would get people blown up by bombs.
I mean their whole,
their legs are being on.
I mean the second,
third day we got there,
we had a kid,
he was a 17 year old kid in his anatomy.
We were taking care of enemies too,
right?
He setting up a roadside bomb to kill
our guys.
Right?
He's from,
he's a 17 year old kid from Pakistan.
It blow,
he blows himself up,
blows up both his legs above the knee,
blows off one of his arm and most of his
hands.
So he's basically,
I mean he's got nothing left,
some are operating on this guy.
We do all these operations is basically
saved the kid's life,
even though he's an enemy.
Cause there's a physician,
you just,
that's just your job.
So what happens to this guy?
He said,
we fixed him up and takes us,
you know,
month to get him stabilized and they
take them out the gate.
The Afghan army just goes and shoots him
in the head rail.
Fuck.
You know,
we're like,
what the hell are we doing here?
You know,
it's just like we're doing all this work
and he's gotten killed.
These people,
they did that because they knew who he
was.
They knew he was an enemy.
And so,
you know,
they don't,
I don't play games,
don't play games.
And so,
and this happened the other way too
around and we saw that seems like a lot
of wasted money.
It is.
It's a waste.
It's heartbreaking.
You know,
you get in there and so we're getting,
I'm getting,
these people are blown up.
Our rockets are whole ways attached to,
I mean,
even if it's the enemy,
like you're in the military,
you're,
you're working as a surgeon,
you're overseas,
you're taken care of.
I mean,
obviously it's a 17 year old kid.
It's almost like Nadia is fall.
This is the thing.
I mean,
a lot of the,
you know,
as a talent man at the time,
and these guys are like,
you know,
if you don't come fight for us,
we're going to kill your family.
Right?
So a lot of these little kids are out
there,
dentists that they don't,
that's not what they want to do.
It's not like to big guys.
So you kind of do,
I mean it's like,
you know,
it's like,
hey,
you know,
it's not my job to punish these people.
It's my job to take care of these
people.
So you there when they shot the kid or
did you see oh,
it is hard about it.
We're like,
what happened to him?
Well,
you get killed,
you know,
we heard about that.
Several of our patients has happened is
it was pretty,
pretty frustrating.
So we get in there and there's like
people like,
I mean little kids were getting these
little kids,
two,
three year old kids stepping on
landmines,
legs blown off.
We had one little three year old kid.
I mean he was,
I mean somebody's drug him behind a
truck for like a mile and they drug this
kid through the streets to the rough
asphalt street and it legs fucking
ripped off.
I mean as kids road rash actually is,
the legs were ripped off.
He was burned everywhere and we're in
her training and stuff.
Why did they do that too?
I don't know.
Just mad at their parents.
I Dunno.
It's just this is not,
this is not a life friendly place,
right?
This is,
life is inconsequential there.
There was a guy,
there was our art,
but we had a pediatrician who was
talking to this guy who was a farmer.
Right.
And he was telling us about his tractor.
He was real proud again to track cause
real expensive to have a tractor in
there.
So what he would do,
because tractors real valuable,
he would have his kids walk in front of
the tractor so they didn't any
landmines.
Oh my God.
So if your kid had he,
he's like,
I can make another kid.
I can't afford it.
This is the mentality there.
You know,
it's just God,
Oh my God,
I can't even hear this.
I mean,
it's crazy stuff.
So we get into,
imagine you have kids.
Could you imagine telling your fucking
kid to walk in front of landmines?
I can do it.
I mean,
it would be,
it would be awful.
Oh Jesus Christ.
So we get this stuff and then once,
you know,
it just gets given gifts.
This keeps getting worse.
I mean,
it's like every day we get these people
with,
you know,
they're blown up and you're looking at
their hip sock.
No,
you let your,
like a guy's laying there was lake
completely gone.
You can see a spine and his hip socket
day in and day out.
We're seeing this stuff.
We get,
um,
we had,
this one we had,
so he's had some,
remember Dick Cheney was the vice
president,
right?
Yeah.
So he flies into the base,
right?
And it was supposed to be secret.
No ones wants to know about it,
but the Taliban guys found out about it,
right?
So what they do is they go to our gate,
set off a suicide bomb,
and they just kill,
I mean,
tons of people and we get all of these
casualties and you know,
most of them are most immersive
millions,
right?
So we get all of these civilian
casualties,
little kids and adults,
you know,
in their suicide vests.
They put all these more,
you know,
like these metal bearings,
like half inch thick metal bearing and
they cover him up and covering them
shit.
So they get infected and they blow
through people.
I mean,
you get people with stuff going into
their brains and shattered bones
everywhere and all these people that are
just,
you know,
dionysus chaos,
all these people,
you get swarmed in and we're getting
this stuff all the time.
This was the biggest one we had.
And so we were,
I mean,
we literally 40 hours straight,
you're working,
you know,
you're trying to save people's lives.
You know,
I'm operating with a general surgeon
when people's bellies,
which I'm not trained to do,
but I'm just helping him trying to do
this stuff.
So in the middle of this operation,
we're in their operating,
you know,
take,
try and take care of these people in,
in Europe and in the operating room was
just a little,
I mean,
it's like a little metal storage
building,
you know,
it's like a,
like a,
like a little,
like if you're moving,
you know,
little pods things,
so they stick a couple of,
uh,
operating beds in there and we're going
as fast and we're wearing body armor and
we have nine millimeter strapped to us
and were operating,
you know,
it's hard to move around.
It's real small.
And we're sitting in there and they say,
hey guys,
we think there's another bomber inside
the hospital,
you know,
in the hospital,
people off.
So you're sitting there going,
you know,
your butthole tightens up and you're
like,
well fuck,
I got to keep operating.
You know,
cause I'm trying to save this guy's
life.
So we keep,
we just like,
well we're going to go and we're going
to go.
Right.
So we just keep,
you know,
we keep operating.
Fortunately they didn't,
they didn't,
they didn't find because they thought I
did.
Somebody snuck in has a casualty.
So they sometimes do that.
They blow people up and then they'd
sneak in as a casualty and blow more
people.
So it's like,
you know,
it's kind of freaky and so I,
I was like,
what an insane environment.
How long were you there for?
Six months.
Yeah.
So that's,
I mean that's,
that's pretty crazy stuff.
So,
you know,
we get out of there and you know,
I mean it was just,
it was just a email is a tremendous
experience.
I mean it was just like,
cause there was nothing I could see that
after that there was like,
that ain't nothing.
Everything I saw after that,
another sergeant was like,
this is no big deal.
Right.
So then I get out and then I,
you know,
get out of the military,
do another five years is taking care of
normal guys in the military.
Right.
Didn't do it.
You take your troops and stuff like
that.
Doing fine.
I worked for all these other hospitals
and did fine.
I never had any problems.
And then I get to this other hospital
and I,
you know,
I joined this group and they make me the
head of the group.
Right.
What kind of group?
It's just like an orthopedic surgery
group.
So,
and there when I got there,
they were like two guys and they weren't
doing hardly any business at all.
I was like really slow.
No one knew they were there.
You know,
they were in part of his big huge group,
had all these other doctors,
but I didn't even know they existed.
So I got there and I said,
well this is crap.
And one of the reasons,
cause no one was seeing anything that
would refuse all these patients.
I got there and I said,
hey man,
I'm going to go talk to all these other
doctors and let him know we're alive,
that we're here and that we're going to
see anything you want to send us and
we'll take care of it.
If we can't,
we'll make sure it gets taken care of
the right way.
So that happened and we started growing,
right?
So we went from two guys to 12 guys and
about three years and so,
and we were very,
very busy.
Real busy group in the rival group from
out of town,
from across the street.
Didn't really like it that much because
we were taking millions of dollars from,
I mean tens of millions of dollars in
their business,
right?
Cause it's orthopedic surgery is very,
very lucrative for a hospital.
There's things like cardiology where
they're putting in stents and surgery.
All these procedure based practices make
a lot of money for hospitals.
So they really like it,
right?
So they're really happy and they're
happy with me.
I'm like the,
you know,
I'd like to hear them right?
Cause they're like,
man,
you're making us a lot of money.
The group Cross town doesn't like me
very much because I'm taking all their
money away.
So they approached us and they said,
you know,
why don't you join our group and you'll,
we'll take care of.
And I said,
no,
I don't want to do that.
And,
but to my partners did,
they eventually left.
So I'm the only holdout guy,
but I'm still going up.
So building the group.
And so I'm like the head,
I'm like the head of the snake,
the rival.
Right.
But here's what kind of happened.
So I'm busy,
I'm doing well,
my patients are happy,
I'm doing really well.
I've got low real low complication
rates,
you know,
everybody's,
I'm very popular.
You know,
I'm on billboards,
I'm on magazines,
I'm on radios,
you know,
I'm,
I'm just,
I'm just there.
Posterboard basically.
Right?
So then as I found with my diet,
I started seeing patients getting better
by just changing her diet.
And when you look in the orthopedics,
you know,
like bone disease,
like arthritis,
there's nothing about died in there.
I mean,
you were studying about it.
If somebody comes into your office,
you know,
you'll tell him,
we can give you some tylenol,
we can give them you some,
uh,
you know,
and other anti inflammatory drug we can,
we can sit some cortisone in your knee.
You know,
if that doesn't work,
maybe we'll,
you know,
we'll fence to send you to physical
therapy.
We might put a scope in there and have
none of that works,
you know,
and it,
this is an end stage and we're going to
replace your knee.
Right.
So what I was finding,
you know,
as I started doing this with patients is
that these patients are getting better
just by changing or not putting him on a
ketogenic diet.
I was,
at that time I was doing Quito.
So I was like,
hey man,
try this.
So mine in my nurse and I had this,
and this is one of the things that kind
of,
I'm very jaded about the way the
business side of medicine is.
Now,
this has been a pretty,
pretty interesting experience for me.
So I had a nurse,
it was just,
I mean she was a wonderful person.
I mean the nicest,
sweetest gal in the world.
She would work so hard for these
patients.
You take care of,
you know,
anything you need done,
you tell her,
hey take care.
And she was just awesome,
right?
The hospital said you're staying in too
late and we're having to pay you over
time.
And she's like,
well,
taking care of patients.
Well we don't care who,
I don't want you to work late because it
costs us too much money.
So it was just like,
it was of these things where you're
starting to see that,
you know,
it's all about the money.
And then we were like,
so all these surgeons,
as a surgeon,
you get used to using certain equipment,
you know,
it's like,
I'm using this particular thing,
have to replace people,
joints and you do it for years and years
and years and you get pretty good at it.
And so at the hospital said is,
hey,
we got a bargain deal with this other
company so your guys are going to use
that.
You know?
We're like,
no,
we don't want to use that.
We've learned how to do this,
won't even how to use that stuff.
So they force everybody to do this,
you know,
just to say,
you know what,
some new surgical equipment,
is that what you're saying?
Yeah.
Well basically you know there's a
system,
it's like if you drive a Ford truck your
whole life,
you know they are,
I understand what you're saying.
And then they say,
no,
you're going to grab Chevy now.
Right,
but this is surgical.
This is third semester.
This is sort of the whole reason is that
we're going to save me money.
All the scraps were pitching.
The ones guys were already using them.
I don't care,
and this is the other group.
We don't care.
But our group was like,
we don't,
we use this stuff,
man.
It's,
it's stuff.
We don't even know how to use this guy.
You're not adapting,
you're not adapting.
You're going to compromise patient care
a little bit.
For this.
So yeah,
this is one of those things where I,
and I was very vocal against this.
I was like,
man,
I don't,
you know,
this is [inaudible],
this is,
this is what we're trained on.
You know,
we're gonna,
we're gonna end up,
um,
you know,
there's,
there's gonna be patients are going to
be problematic from this stuff.
So that was an aside thing.
And then there was a system where it's
another thing they put in the,
the,
you know,
this is the one thing that all
physicians hate this thing called an
electronic medical record.
He was a computer based record.
Not that it's a computer based thing,
but they're awful.
I mean they sit there and their main
function is to collect billing and to do
coding.
So it's a capture as much information as
you can so you can build more.
Right.
That's,
that's you know why hospital and liked
them.
So they puts us on you and it's like,
you know,
no,
it's like really hard to take,
you know,
to put good information there.
Cause all it is to generate a bunch of
data that's totally illogical.
You know,
you can't,
you look at it,
it's like you get 20 pages of Bs and
two,
two paragraphs of stuff you need.
Right?
So where did it all go bad?
So then we,
so basically what happened is when I
started telling peach people I don't
want to,
you know,
I'm tardy,
I started talking to people out of
surgery,
right?
I started saying,
I don't think you need surgery.
And then I started talking to the
administrators and say,
hey guys,
I really want to spend a day a week just
doing lifestyle counseling.
I don't want to,
you know,
constantly do this cause I think this
can work resentful.
You making the cutting motion like it's
costly surgery.
Right?
And so,
and they are basically said,
no,
there's no appetite for that.
Your skill as a surgeon,
we want you there.
And you know,
in other words,
keep making us a lot of money,
right?
So I'm like,
you know,
and,
and my nurse will take him and I was
printing out,
I made a list of all his reading.
You remember,
like Gary,
I know he had,
Gary Thompson denied,
had his book and I had Nina Teicholz his
book on and I had just got him
butterball up rigs,
you know,
all these key to Janneke things,
references.
And I was handing them out 2025 of those
every single day.
And I was spending time with the
patients,
you know,
because normally you'd only get like
eight,
eight minutes to see a patient,
you know,
figured out the problem,
figuring out a plan and go,
go,
go.
And I was like,
now spending 20 minutes talking to these
guys about diet.
And so,
you know,
then I'm seeing less patients in the
hospital keeps saying,
you know,
we don't want,
we don't really like that.
So because I was ahead of the group and
I was well liked by everybody,
I had really good patient records.
I mean,
really good,
uh,
patient satisfaction.
You'll really low complication rates.
I mean,
they were,
they're like,
well,
we don't like that.
So then they go,
there's something called Peer Review,
right?
So they can just pull your records and
say,
we don't like the way you did this.
And you know,
we're gonna,
we're gonna criticize your work.
And so they did that and they went
through there.
And this is one of the things they said,
well,
every surgeon will have x amount of
complications,
right?
It's like,
you know,
if you do,
uh,
you know,
a hundred surgeries,
about 5% of the time there's going to be
some complications.
Somebody is going to get an infection,
some he's going to bleed too much.
I'm just gonna get a blood clot off as
an orthopedic surgeon.
Maybe one of the screws you put in
breaks or something.
Like those things are all complication
that happens to everybody no matter
what.
So what they said is there,
there's a low threshold,
right?
There's like a,
you know,
we're going to say every year we're
going to give you two complications that
were your fault,
right?
Cause most of the time you have a
complication.
It's like mentors,
nothing.
I could've done equipment failure or
slow,
they'll say,
you made the wrong decision.
That liberal complicates.
So they'll say you can get to a year,
right.
And it doesn't matter if you do a
hundred surgeries a year or you do 500
surgeries a year,
the numbers still too.
Right.
And I'm like,
you know,
cause I,
cause I was there for like five years
and like every year was like one,
one,
just nothing minimal.
Right.
One year,
one year they go back,
so you had three this year?
I'm like,
yeah,
but I did five times as many surgeries
than anybody else.
And I said,
well it doesn't matter.
We're going to work and still put it
through peer review.
So what they do is they hire,
I remember this other group that I was
pissing off and it's taken $10 million a
year from,
they hire their guy,
that guy to look through my stuff.
Why would they do that?
Because that's what they wanted to do.
But why would they do that if that
person on that other side is the
competition?
Because he was in the position to do it.
Right.
Okay.
So,
and that's not supposed to have it.
It'd be like if you were a ability for
guy and said,
I want the Bella tour guide to review
the UFC.
Right?
I think Joe Rogan sucks is an announcer.
I'm have a billet military guy go after
him,
right?
So it's total conflict of interest,
So I,
you know,
I'm in,
I'm like this naive ethical guide.
It's like,
well,
you know,
I know I could care and reasons for
doing fine.
And then,
um,
you know,
I was just like,
okay,
well,
that's fine.
And so they get it back and the guy,
and they looked at,
they looked at a dozen cases or they've
selected,
you know,
so like you pick whatever they want.
And they said,
well,
he said,
I think six these cases were below
average.
You know,
I don't like the way you documented
stuff and this and I disagree what you
did.
So I'm like,
fine.
They said,
well,
that's okay.
You know,
um,
you know,
you're fine.
I said,
what do I need to stop operating?
Someone who said,
no,
you're fine.
Well,
we're gonna do is we're going to get an
independent review,
right?
And this is supposed to be someone with
no conflicts of interest,
right?
So the way this this is supposed to
happen is that they were supposed to let
me see what the cases are and put my
comments in there,
right.
And they were supposedly supposed to be
totally in.
So what they did and did instead is they
wouldn't let me know any
of the cases.
They told me you can't see anything.
Right.
And the guy that had the conflicts of
interest that gave him all of his
findings and send them to this guy.
Right.
And this guy and I,
and I,
you know,
I don't know the situation where this
guy,
but you know,
I found this out about six months later,
he is either senile or totally drunk.
I mean it was just like,
you know,
so he gets this report,
right?
And it's just bad.
It's like,
it looks really bad and I'll talk about
some of the details in a second,
but it just looks really bad.
And they come,
they pull me in the office and say,
we got this really bad enough
independent report,
right?
And I'm like,
well,
what cases where we can't tell you but
it's really bad and we're going to,
we're going to suspend you privileges.
We're not gonna let you work here
anymore.
So essentially what you're trying to say
is they targeted you and they targeted
you because you were changing what you
were doing and you were trying to
counsel people with lifestyle and they
decided to pick on you and try to find
things that were wrong.
And some of the past surgeries that you
do.
I think it was a combination.
I think there was a combination of
income,
no problems.
We're not,
some people weren't doing it
intentionally,
but there were,
there was definitely a,
possibly some of the,
some of that going on.
But anyway,
so they get this report and the guy,
there's,
there's two people,
they bring me in the office say,
you know,
we're going to shut down.
You can't go to your clinic.
You can't talk to anybody you work with.
We're going to deny you access to all
clinic charts.
We're going to shut off your email.
You can't look at anything.
Right?
Like,
um,
like I just committed murder.
Like I'm some pariah and then they say,
then the guy and I'm like,
you know,
I'm like,
I mean it's like something like kid just
died.
I mean,
this is something I spent my whole life
training for.
You know,
I'm doing this stuff.
And it's like,
you know,
I mean,
it's like you're like days and
confusion,
numb.
I mean,
I'm like numb.
I'm like,
I don't know.
I'm going to drive my fucking car off a
cliff.
You know,
you're like suicidal almost,
you know?
So the guy comes to me and he goes,
hey man,
we got this really bad stuff on you is
going to go really bad.
We're going to take it to a committee
and a couple of days.
And I think the best thing you can do is
just say,
you're sorry,
write a letter.
I'll even help you write this letter.
You know,
basically say,
confess it to you,
did the wrong thing.
So I'm like,
I didn't,
I didn't have a lawyer at the time and
didn't know what's going on.
So I said,
okay,
I'll do this.
And so I write this letter saying,
yeah,
you know,
I probably could have done no stuff
different.
I Dunno what the cases were,
but probably,
and so you're saying this without even
have reviewed the cases that they're
condemning you on?
Absolutely,
because I was fuck did you not get a
lawyer?
I did afterwards,
but I don't know.
Cause I know,
you know,
I'd been a straight laced ethical guy my
whole life.
So when you did afterwards the lawyer go
back and look at that,
the confession or whatever you would
call it,
she says,
well this is preposterous because you're
not even talking about a specific case.
Well she said it was probably something
he shouldn't have done and I would have
Kelsey,
but this guy was on the committee that
condemn me.
Right?
So this is a guy that's honestly,
they set you up.
So in some ways,
so this is what I want to say that
because you still wanting to be a
doctor.
Well,
so this is,
um,
so basically they'd take this committee,
right?
And they hand this report.
It says all this bad stuff and the hand,
my confession,
right.
And this is all I,
this is basically what they have to go
on.
No one knows anything about the cases.
And this
is all these people that are doctors,
but they're not surgeons.
Right.
All they are is,
it would be like if you were reviewing
mma guys,
like,
so let's say you want to kick somebody
out of the UFC because you said it's
performance isn't up to snuff.
And you went to a much a tennis players
and golfers and said,
hey man,
we don't think he hasn't his take 10% it
sucks.
And I see what I'm saying.
So these people have no frigging clue,
right?
They have no clue about what I did.
They don't have specific cases to go
specific cases.
And I'm not allowed to talk about this
cause I don't know the specific cases.
So then I railroad job.
So,
so then I,
you know,
I,
I kind of will come out of this haze and
I looked and I said,
we'll give you a fair hearing.
Says what they call it.
A fear of federal law requires us to
give you a fair hearing.
Right?
So I get a lawyer and this is expensive
as shit,
you know,
I'm not,
I don't have an income anymore.
So I'm spending all this money in the
lawyers fees and it's taken the hospital
to drags out.
They won't release records for like six
months.
So six months goes by.
I mean here I got four small kids.
I'm like,
fuck,
am I going to feed my kid?
My kids are in school like one autistic
son and he's therapy and you know,
this is,
this is tough,
you know,
so going through this stuff,
so six months ago,
the layer and then I finally get the
cases right and I started looking
through the cases and what the guy
wrote.
And not only are there errors,
there are egregious errors and there's
multiple when they're just horrible.
I mean,
they're just so wrong.
I,
that's why I said the guy has seen her
drunk.
I'll give you a couple of examples and
any orthopedic surgeons is listening to
us know immediately what I'm talking
about.
But I'll try and make it make sense for
other people.
So the of these 12 cases,
two of them were something called a
reverse shoulder replacement.
So what happens is,
you know,
if you showed a word's out,
you can replace your shoulder,
right?
Just shoulder replacements on people.
What do you put in there?
Like some sort of an artificial joint.
Yeah.
So then this is,
what is this what I'm talking about
some,
normally it's a ball and socket joint,
right?
So there's something called a reverse
shoulder replacement,
which you basically switch it around and
you put the ball where the socket was
and the socket where the ball was,
which sounds totally crazy,
right?
This was developed in France in the 80s
and then the FDA approved this in 2004
it's a 2004 was approved in the u s and
originally it was approved for one
reason,
right?
If your shoulder is totally arthritic,
you know,
real bad,
Arthur and you don't have a rotator cuff
anymore and it's completely gone.
Right?
So that's what it was first approved
for.
But over the years,
over the next five,
10 years,
people started using it for all these
other things.
And getting really,
really good results with it.
So if you come in there with a blasted
apart shoulder that's crashed and
broken,
you're an older person.
People do that all the time.
And so that's,
that's what I did.
I basically put a noise,
you know,
reverse shoulder and a person that broke
their arm at this twice.
And not only did the patient do well,
I mean the patient was happy as can be.
They're great.
They're like,
no one knew what the outcomes of these
patients in this patient is.
Happy as can be.
But the guy writes because he's old,
I think,
or drunk or doesn't know the new record.
He hasn't read literature and 10 he put
it in backwards.
No,
he puts,
it's not indicated for this student.
The only reason to do,
and it's for an arthritic guy with a,
with a missing road ticket.
But he doesn't know that over the last
10 years,
all kinds of different reasons to use
it.
So he basically tells us committee he's
doing the wrong operation when anybody
denay that that's not the case.
Right.
So there's another case.
It a guy.
No,
it's okay.
We don't have to keep just going over
case after case.
It's going to get a little dragon.
I know,
but what,
where does it stand right now?
So basically what happens is,
so they drag us out for a year and a
half,
right?
And they finally,
you know,
and at the end,
I tell him,
cause I gotta tell you this part,
so I go through,
this is important.
I go through and compile all of these
cases,
right?
And get all the data to refute this and
pull all these references and textbooks
and all this stuff.
And I'm like,
this is a walk in the park,
right?
I'm going to,
uh,
you know,
anybody that sees us in the right mind
is going to see that they screwed up and
there's all these Arabs that's wrong.
So I see in discovery process,
you send all this information in and
then they fail.
Then they realize that,
wait a minute,
there's a lot of Eric's in here.
So now they have to pick a hearing
officer,
right?
Who's like the judge,
His word goes to,
they pick it up,
they get another search,
like give me a list of surgeons to
choose from.
He said,
you can have any of these guys you want.
And I looked through the list and
there's one guy,
you remember that group that I was
competing with,
he's in that group and I'm like,
I don't want him cause he's on the other
group.
And they said,
no,
he just retired and we went and we're
going to make you use him.
Right?
So they pick the judge and then on top
of that they pay him.
So they're paying this guy,
right.
So they review all this stuff and I've
got this stuff and I'm going through
case after case where I'm like,
the patient didn't get,
the patient was doing great,
they didn't get hurt.
There's nothing wrong with them.
And the lawyers from the other side,
I'm like,
well you can't do,
there's no harm,
no foul stuff.
I'm like,
what are you talking about?
You know,
no one got,
everybody's doing great.
But he's like,
well I think,
you know,
you could've done something different or
something like that.
And He,
like,
if you look at a malpractice case,
the first thing you have to do is prove
harm,
right?
If no one gets hurt,
there's nothing there.
And it's not that anyone,
no one got hurt,
no one did.
But it's just like so the,
so the guy at the end of it goes through
and he says,
yeah,
there were a lot of errors,
right?
And they're paying this guy and they
chick chosen.
But I think you gave patients too much
choice in their care,
which is,
I'm like,
what are you talking about?
You know,
so if I,
if the criticism was that was,
that's all they had pieces now he said
it was really bad air and they said you
gave patients too much choice and you
didn't document stuff as well as you
should have.
Right.
And I still think that they should have
just,
just manage it.
So this is,
this is the decision to make based on
that.
And I will guarantee if anybody who was
on that committee that knew me cause
people knew me on the committee knew I
was a good guy,
they never had problems with me.
So that's why they were shocked when
this came out.
But if they knew that information,
I'm 100% convinced that would be a
difference.
So what does it stand?
So then you know,
I get done with that and then the state
gets involved because the state has to
respond.
Any complaints the state state gets this
complaint stayed in New Mexico and it's
kind of weird because my next door
neighbors on the state board and I'm
just like totally avoiding the guy cause
I don't want to influence anything.
Right.
I'd be giving them flowers.
No,
but I just didn't want to do.
And I even told him,
I said,
hey,
my next door neighbor is on your board.
Right.
So I don't want,
I want to be totally ethical about this.
This is a story.
So I,
you know,
they,
they said,
dude,
all my flowers.
Yeah.
Well maybe we can maybe give him an elk
stack or something like that.
So then the board gets us and they say,
man,
this is,
this is a
bad recommendation and we're going to
give you two options.
You can suspend your license,
you know,
you can voluntarily suspend your,
each surrender your license,
or you can go to trial.
You know,
we can do another hearing,
which probably didn't take a year.
It's going to cost you tons of money,
you know,
which I don't,
I'm just tired of this.
I'm tired of lawyers spending all this
money and I'm not,
I'm still trying to figure out how am I
gonna feed my kids.
So then,
you know,
the state says,
or what you can do is we'll send you to
a place and I'll evaluate you
independently.
And then if everything goes well,
we'll give you a license back.
So that I said,
okay,
that's what I'm gonna do.
Cause I'm tired of this.
I don't want to spend $100,000 and wait
a year when I can go to this place and
spend $12,000 and get evaluated and go
from there.
So I was,
that's where I was this week.
In fact,
I was in Denver being with these other
surgeons and they were just like going
through all this case,
case,
case.
What would you do?
And I am clearly,
you know,
even though I haven't done this stuff in
two years,
I'm clearly convinced that they're going
to say,
hey man,
you're fine.
And they're going to say,
here,
go operate with somebody for taking lots
of,
look at those cases where you were
judged upon poorly.
They're not,
they're not.
because they wanted to be totally into
fucking insane.
So,
um,
how do you make a lemon?
Now I'm living off my savings.
You know,
I saved up some money.
So I lived off that and that's,
that's mostly yet,
you know,
so I'm just kind of slowly watching my
savings dwindle down.
Jesus Christ has got to be stressful.
It's kind of stressful.
I mean,
you know,
I've got a girlfriend in Mexico living,
but I,
you know,
I don't want to be,
but I've got kids who,
we've got kids,
I've got a kid with her and I've got
three kids with my ex wife and they're
all young kids.
And so I'm back.
And so I said I'm traveling back and
forth,
man,
back and forth,
you know,
trying to support these kids.
You know,
I had to pull my kids out of school,
I had to put them in a different school
because the income wasn't there anymore.
And you know,
it's so it's,
it's kind of a pain.
It's Kinda kinda sucks.
So where's the Stan as far as like
getting your license reinstated?
Yeah,
so probably,
so I was just in Denver,
they said it'll take about eight weeks.
So they'll give me a,
they'll give me a plan,
they'll say,
okay,
we think that,
you know,
I am almost a hundred percent convinced
they're going to say,
you know,
we need you to go work with some dude
for a couple months cause you're out of
practice.
And I think I'll probably end up doing
that.
Then the board,
the State Board will review what they
say.
And in longer they say,
hey man,
you're,
you know what you're doing,
they'll give it back to me.
So insane.
Yeah.
So anyway,
it's,
you know,
again,
I don't blame the state board.
I don't believe the people who are on
the committee because they were
clueless.
I didn't know what I,
I blame someone competence by the
administrators,
you know,
and,
and just whoever reviewed me,
you know,
if it were a caveman times Joe,
I go with a big club and like what the
F,
you know,
I understand,
man,
that's a,
that's very disheartening.
But it's,
I've,
I have a friend who's going through a
very similar type situation,
uh,
who was also a surgeon.
There's a,
yeah,
it's theirs.
I think people need to understand that
the medical business is in fact a
business now.
And we think of hospitals as being these
completely,
you know,
a egalitarian places that just,
they,
they exist to heal people and to do the
best job.
They sort of do,
but they also,
they need to make a lot of money.
Well,
they got to pay the light bills.
I mean,
I understand,
I understand that.
But then there's a point,
you know,
it gets kind of like you've got to make
a decision between patient care and,
you know.
Yeah.
And the CEO making,
making a little extra now they do that
with animals too.
I mean,
you gotta be really careful.
I had a friend who had a recent
situation happened with his dog where,
uh,
they were telling his dog him,
his dog needed to get some crazy surgery
and he didn't have the money for it.
And he's like,
are you sure?
You sure they need to end?
He said,
I had to ask them over and over and over
again.
And he said,
in filing the veterinarian said,
well,
we could try a steroid,
uh,
on the dog and see if that works.
Fucking fixed it 100%.
Yeah.
And the steroid costs like 150 bucks
versus some $30,000 surgery.
But they kept pushing this surgery,
which would have fused that dog's discs.
They were like,
this needs to happen,
need to do this.
And he's like,
well,
there's no other options and we've
exhausted all possible options.
And then finally after asking over and
over and over again,
she suggested meekly this,
which instantly fixed it.
Yeah.
It's Kinda like two months.
The dog was 100% you know it's got,
no,
no.
Cause I know he hit Chris,
Chris around here a while.
I'm going to listen to a little bit of
stuff.
And then in his premise at the
beginning,
which I haven't read his book yet,
but I think it's great.
I mean,
here's the problem with Western
medicine.
You know,
we're facing this,
I mean it's like a war against chronic
disease.
It's like we're being invaded by,
you know,
remember Independence Day where that all
of this in doctors,
we got bb guns.
I mean the stuff we are shooting at them
doesn't work for chronic disease.
Now.
Acute stuff,
it's different.
You know,
there's some stuff that we have this
wonderful technology,
but the run of the mill diabetes and
obesity doctors are great for fixing
broken jump joy.
There's no doubt about that.
Even even like arthritis and I sell
every day,
you know,
if we were trained properly in nutrition
and exercise,
you know,
that's what I've known my whole life,
and I know what I'm doing exercise wise.
But you know,
if we were allowed to do that and
instead of training all these,
you know,
radiology technicians and blood draw
technicians and nursing assistants,
if you had an army of preventative
people,
bit of medicine people,
you know,
and then we train all these people to go
into people's homes.
You know,
I think Chris was talking about that and
just get the crap out of their diet and
show them how to be healthier,
you know?
I mean you would,
you would save,
you know,
it's funny watching the politicians
debate about healthcare,
how to fund it.
You know,
it's like you guys are arguing about the
tie can't tannic as it's coming up in
the iceberg and you're not,
you're arguing about the color of the
deck chairs.
I mean,
we're going over a cliff and we're not
fixing it.
By keeping putting bandaids,
you're not going to write it.
The technology's not going to fix
diabetes.
Nutritionist,
you know that this is a year of
essentially dealing with the problem and
it's already gotten to a point where
you're in the hospital.
Yeah.
I mean there's,
you know,
like I said,
there's a guy,
Peter Attia,
I don't know if you know who he is,
but he talks about when he was a
surgeon,
he felt like he was at the bottom of a
building and somebody is throwing eggs
off and his job is to catch the eggs.
Right?
And he's like,
well,
why would just have the guy stop fucking
thrown out?
But that's what medicine is.
You're just catching me eggs.
And so instead of it,
we should be investing,
you know,
all,
we talk about prevention,
but it's bullshit.
We don't do anything for prevention.
It's so little.
And then the problem,
the problem is,
a lot of it is,
it doesn't work the way we've designed,
you know.
Yeah.
There's a,
there's a lot of money in fixing you and
there's not a whole lot of money in
telling you to eat.
Well,
no,
there's not.
There's not a lot.
But it is a changing climate though
with,
because of,
uh,
people at Chris Kresser and Robb Wolf
and doctor Rhonda Patrick and a lot of
others,
they're giving out really good nutrition
advice and people changing the way they
eat and think about food and it's having
a massive effect on the inflammation
that they carry in their body.
I know so many people that used to have
joint pain.
Um,
uh,
a great example is,
um,
uh,
the primal kitchen assistant mark
Sisson's book,
which is fantastic.
And His story mark story about having
his own,
um,
inflammatory issues with his hands.
He had some pretty severe arthritis and
he thought it was just going to be with
him forever.
He changed his diet,
reduces all the refined carbohydrates.
It goes on this protein,
high fat diet,
and it all goes away.
I mean,
there's so many examples of that.
And I just watched this documentary
called what's with wheat and it's all
about,
uh,
glyphosate in the wheat,
roundup.
And how when they say it's safe for
people to consume,
they say,
well,
it only affects plants and bacteria.
They'd be like,
well what about your microbiome?
Your microbiome is filled with bacteria
and you're killing that stuff.
Like we don't think of that as being an
issue.
You know,
we don't think of sedentary lifestyle as
being an issue when it comes to the,
the,
the ultimate cause for you to wind up in
the hospital needing surgery.
But it absolutely is.
No,
it is.
I can tell you one of the things I used
to see,
cause you know,
when you're,
when you're a surgeon you like somebody
comes in with bad arthritis and you
placed her knee and they feel better for
a while and you're like,
oh,
that's great man,
I really helped this person.
Then they come in next year and there
are other needs all jacked up.
And then you a that,
well you should have just done
something.
So they didn't need our threat.
It didn't get,
you know,
didn't need surgery.
On the other time that I've had
conversations with people that their dad
that needs a,
an artificial knee and I'm like,
are you sure?
Are you sure?
Like,
yeah,
he's limping bad.
I mean,
he really can't take it anymore.
Like,
have you exhausted all possible options?
Like what have you done about the Diet?
No,
he won't.
He's not into that.
He's,
oh,
he's not into that.
Okay,
well here's a problem because no one's
demonstrated the Diet works.
But I will tell you this is,
this is,
and you know,
well,
no one's demonstrated it in terms of
like scientific,
right?
But I will tell you that,
you know,
just,
cause I told you because I'm a freak
because I,
I'm just eating meat and I'm doing this
athletic stuff and nobody says you're an
l or your genetic freak or whatever.
You're an n equals one.
So we made this website called n equals
many meters,
other air force guy that he's also a
corner bar.
We got this thing,
we said,
well what if people started gathering
this information together and we could
start documenting that.
And that's what we did.
So we put out a survey on twitter.
I said,
hey,
how many of you guys would be willing to
go 90 days and just eat,
eat a bunch of steaks?
And I had like 400 I didn't have that
many followers by like 400 people.
Yeah,
we'll do it.
That's amazing.
So we put the,
we,
you know,
we developed this website and it's
called n equals many Dotcom for people
want to see.
So we developed this website and then we
start getting these first equal sign or
eat q eqs spell.
I don't think I put an equals on a,
on a website now.
And he and e q u a l many doctors,
right?
So we do this and we get all these
people that sign up and we ended up
having about close to a hundred people
just do 90 days.
It just any meat.
And then we,
and it's,
and again,
there's a lot of scientific route things
you can criticize about this.
You know,
it's just guys ate meat and egg though
still.
But you know,
when we got done and I've got the
results that we just,
you know,
we're still analyzing the data because
we're all doing this for free and we're
going to weren't,
you know,
we're trying to get people to help us
analyze the data and you know,
but of these hundred people,
you know,
there's about 85 action of these people.
We ask them what happened to your
general health?
What happened to your sexual health?
What happened to your exercise capacity?
What happens to your gi health,
your skin,
every,
we asked all these questions and there
was maybe one,
1% where they said it got worse.
99% got better,
much better.
Or say to say,
you know,
it was just like unanimously everybody
got,
you know,
pretty much either the same or is it
possible that there's some bias in that
group because they're following you?
Absolutely.
Yeah.
I mean I'm well aware of that,
you know,
and that's,
that's,
you know,
but it's interesting but then we're
getting some old lab data.
Cause I know you like about lab data.
So I get people and I don't have access
to all the data and I didn't want it.
I didn't want to have access to the
date.
I don't want to bias myself against it.
So I'm getting fed the data and I'm
seeing that people's blood pressure is
normalizing people's hemoglobin.
A one C,
which has never had measure glucose is
normalizing people's inflammation.
Markers are normalizing,
you know,
all these markers of disease are going
in the right direction.
You know,
we're just seeing good stuff,
you know,
because in a lot of the people will say
meat causes diabetes.
Me Causes Hypertension.
He had,
the only time I've ever seen me causes
diabetes.
Isn't that wacky?
What?
The health documentary,
which has been widely disproven and we
had on it,
rewrote a whole piece about that,
debunking that and like how much stuff
and that it's like fake science.
Like what they're saying about meat
causing diabetes.
There's no evidence of that.
Yeah.
I mean they,
they,
they look some,
they use them associational stuff and
that's all they ever do.
I mean it's like some associations,
but they're putting it out as if it's
100% factual.
And like the sounding the alarms,
like this is what's causing diabetes.
It's meet me while they're completely
ignoring the consumption of all these
refined carbohydrates,
these people are eating with the meat.
Yeah,
I mean 100%.
I mean that's totally true.
I mean the uh,
you know,
and so one of the thing is so nice about
studying these people,
they're just eating meat.
I mean,
you isolate a variable you to isolate.
So we know what happens when you just
eat.
No.
Are they allowed to take supplements
during the time we had so many?
We the what we said we document it.
Yeah.
We had them document stuff and some of
them do some,
you know,
it was Kinda like one of those things
where we,
cause we,
we'd never done this before and like
we're,
and we made them document all kinds of
stuff and a lot of people,
some of the people initially dropped out
can we made them document too much
stuff.
Like it's too much of a hassle looking
at Portland stuff.
So we had percentage dropped
out because he just didn't want
documents stuff.
We had a certain percentage of dropped
out because they didn't feel,
they felt like they had the low energy.
Right.
And so a lot of people when they do
this,
they just can't eat very much.
I mean,
they get full and they're not eating
enough.
And so that's one of the biggest things
I tell people when they switch over this
eat meat.
Like it's your job.
That's what I tell them.
You got to eat edd initially.
Didn't they just eat until they're not
hungry anymore?
Well the problem is you,
the problem is a lot of people lose
weight on this.
You know,
a lot of people get lean on this stuff
is that,
you know,
your hunger goes down pretty low because
you're,
you know,
you're eating a lot of fat and eating a
lot of protein.
You know,
especially if you're eating,
if you're eating Ribeye steaks,
you know,
that's probably about 70% fat,
30% protein,
something like that.
So I mean it's,
it's really,
really satisfying.
And so,
you know,
they,
they tend to,
they tend to under,
cause no one's used to like if I sold
you joe go eat four pounds of meat a
day,
they're going to be like,
well,
I mean,
I know you like eating meat,
but I mean even that's probably a big
town a lot.
It's a lot,
you know,
and so to get used to that,
it takes awhile.
You don't,
it depends on your activity level.
Cause I work out pretty damn hard and I
do it pretty often.
Um,
so I mean,
they do some crazy shit man.
I saw you box jumps.
Yeah.
I mean,
I,
you know,
this is like I said,
this is uh,
uh,
you know,
back to that glycolytic stuff.
I do.
I mean I'm,
I'm,
you know,
I'm Mike,
Capacity to extend is great.
And one of the things is because I,
you felt no difference.
I'm sorry to interrupt you,
but you felt no difference between,
um,
going from the ketogenic diet to eating
meat or did it feel like you had more
energy?
I had more energy,
I had better libido.
You know,
you wake up every day,
you know you're ready to go.
You know,
it's like,
uh,
you know,
I've had a couple people that,
and I haven't tested it,
but I have a couple of people who have
done this and again,
we need to get more data.
I've had a couple people have done it.
It said their testosterone level went
up,
you know,
like they went on to all meet their
testosterone went up about 20% and so I
don't,
I was like,
well that's interesting.
You know,
I don't put a lot of faith and just a
couple of anecdotes.
So that happened.
So a lot of people that go on the
ketogenic diet because the cholesterol
is actually the precursor to
testosterone.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
It's kind of interesting if you look at,
you know,
red meat consumption in the U S and in
1977 so red meat has gone down about 30
to 40% really?
We used to be way more in the 70s we ate
about 30 40% more red meat than we do
now.
No kidding.
Yep.
And also our testosterone levels have
dropped significantly and population
testosterone levels have dropped about
that same amount.
Bullied a lot of red mean I would've
never imagined me
the last.
Now we listened.
We used to.
Wow.
Yeah.
So here's another interesting fact.
Hong Kong,
right now if you look up,
if you google Hong Kong life expectancy,
they live the longest out of anybody on
the world.
Right.
They eat about 40% more red meat than we
do in the US and them.
And they have the longest lived people
in the world,
which is interesting.
Yeah.
I'd read something that said that 100%
of all people that live over a hundred
no,
it was some high number of all people
that live over a hundred consume red
meat.
Yeah.
I don't doubt it.
You know,
it's interesting cause you know the,
the other vegans really liked to point
out,
okay now it's a blue zone and edelman
and I suppose they looked at the people
that
lived over a hundred in,
in Okinawa.
None of them were vegetarians.
All of them ate meat.
Yeah.
There's not a lot.
Not a lot of good solid evidence that
being a Vegan is a solution to a long
life.
Well,
I mean,
you know that,
you know,
obviously there's different propaganda
out there and I think,
you know,
here's what I would say.
You know,
if you want to do veganism and it makes
you healthy,
fun,
most people can't do it.
I mean,
we know that about right,
but the thing is,
we're not just talking about if you want
to do it,
we're talking about people that are
proselytizing,
like they have this idea and they push
this idea down everybody's throats.
But if we're just looking at the actual
data,
the health data,
like what's good for you,
what's bad for you?
It's it.
There's no like overwhelming evidence
that the Vegan ways,
the way to go,
no,
there's not.
I mean,
they're there,
their studies,
they like to push,
but there's also studies that show that,
you know,
the opposite effect.
You know,
if you look at the epic Oxford study,
which had about 60,000 people in it,
you know,
they showed that vegetarians,
vegans live no longer than meat eaters.
There's no difference.
Right?
Even though the mediators are probably
the guys that don't care about their
health.
True.
So it made,
not only is it not protective,
but it may be a negative.
You can look at it and study out of
Australia,
it looked at 240,000 people called the
45 and up study.
Same thing,
vegans,
vegetarians,
no loan,
no lever,
no longer life,
no better health.
And so it's Kinda like,
you know,
who do you believe in?
These guys have their studies that
they're going to quote and you can share
it.
And I can cherry pick all day and other
people can cherry pick all day.
It's just bs.
So my best advantage,
advices,
and this is I think the best advice you
can give anybody.
You know,
until we start seeing dudes walking
around that are in shape.
And Jack did 120 years old,
you're not going to know what the right
thing to do is.
And so the best advice you can have is
to get strong,
get healthy,
you know,
move well,
do everything you can to make your
health good.
And that's the best you can do because
if you're healthy today,
odds are you're going to be healthier
tomorrow.
So you know the fact that you know,
Joe,
you're still got a lot of muscle on you
at 50 means you're more likely to have
someone you're 60 I mean there's just no
dot.
That's the biggest correlated the best.
One of the best predictors of long life
is your exercise capacity.
And I think we should bring this up
while we're talking about Vegan diets or
southern darts.
If you have a standard American diet of
even eating a bunch of shitty food and
fried chicken and bullshit and
cheeseburgers and sodas and you go
Vegan,
you will be healthier.
Sure.
Well cause you're going to remove all
that shitty process food out of your
diet all the night try.
It's all the stuff that's unnecessary.
All the preservatives.
If you do that,
you will be healthier.
But it doesn't necessarily mean the
Vegan diets the way to go.
I mean,
it just,
it means that the American diet that
everybody like rightly criticized as is
the wrong way to go vegan diet.
Certainly better than that.
Yeah,
I mean you can do bob on any,
it's better than that.
I mean just like in a lot of things,
you know,
this is another point I bring on,
cause one of the,
one of the differences between what I
sort of think is healthy and I don't
know,
I'll come out and say,
I don't know for sure.
I'm still learning this stuff and I'm
willing to investigate it.
You know,
I'm willing to put my body to test and
have other people,
you know,
give me data.
But what I,
what we want,
there's a big group out there and says
you shouldn't
eat a lot of protein.
You should really restrict your protein.
There is some data that talks about
something called [inaudible] that you
know,
maybe you know,
it causes cancer,
maybe it inhibits longevity and then
these lesser animals like mice and a
little tadpoles nematode things and you
know,
to,
and then there was another group of
scientists out there is getting Stuart
Phillips out of Canada that's looking at
that.
And it shows that,
you know,
the more protein you have,
especially when you get older,
the,
the longer you're going to preserve
muscle,
the better your quality of life isn't
likely longer you're going to live,
you know?
And so what,
you know,
what happens if you autopsy and old
person,
you know,
you get some money and you got an old
folks home,
their brain has shrunk.
I mean,
their muscles have shrunk and away the
protein in their bones have shrunk and
away their kidneys have shrunk,
their hardest shrunk,
their skin has shrunk,
everything's shrunk because lost all
this protein.
What happens is as you get older and
older,
you lose some of the capacity to digest
meat.
And so what happens is where does your
body get that protein from?
It just starts taking it from yourself.
You start autocad cannibalizing yourself
to sustain function.
You know,
it's sustained cellular function.
So if you're not getting that replaced,
you know,
through diet and meet as outstanding
source of that,
you know,
you're going to be frailer and frailer.
You know,
we have an obesity epidemic,
but we also have a frailty epidemic.
There's people that are just,
I mean by the time they're 40 I mean
they may be obese but their weakest
B,
Yeah.
There's so many people that are just
sedentary lifestyles.
One of the biggest killers of your body
for sure.
And there's so many people that you look
at it,
I'm like,
I was talking to a guy the other day and
it looked like you could just grab his
arm and pull it off his body.
Like his,
his shoulders were sunk in.
There was like no muscle tone.
It all.
And he had no exercise is that there was
none in his life ever.
Like maybe they made them do gym in high
school and that was it.
And he's just,
he's younger than me and he was falling
apart.
I can,
you know,
you and I had 50 or like the bar for a
healthy 50 or normal 50 year old is you
know,
way down low and you know,
we're like total outliers,
you know this,
the fact that we exercise and have a
little muscle,
I mean that puts you in the 99% tall
and it's interesting if you just
continue it.
The thing about it is like I,
if I take a week off man,
boy do I feel it more at 50 than I did
it third?
No,
it's crazy.
Yeah,
that's true.
But I could still get back in shape and
once you get back in shape,
you just got to keep it going and if you
just keep it going,
it will work for you,
your body.
It's what we compare.
It's really interesting because what we
compare in terms of normal body
function,
like the normal capacity that your body
has,
we're really generally looking at people
that had just the average person.
Well the average person doesn't really
exercise very hard.
They don't.
So we don't have a lot of data on people
that are in their fifties it's still
good.
You know what?
I'm not letting this go.
I'm going to keep this fucking body
strong.
I'm going to make sure I lift heavy
weights.
I'm going to do hard cardio.
I'm going to do sprinting and kickboxing
and a bunch of shit that requires
explosive energy.
And uh,
if you do that,
your body can stay vibrant,
but you have to be diligent.
It's very,
for people to understand this,
this is not,
if you're just a casual person who just
kind of like half as is,
oh,
maybe we'll take a spin class.
Good luck,
bitch.
You,
your body's gonna die.
It's going to rot off and fall apart.
But if you just decide to be militant
about this,
you can keep a functional body far
longer.
And it's not just about ego,
it's also just about the use of your
meat vehicle.
Like my body could do a lot of shit that
most people's bodies can't.
Like if I want to pick something up,
I don't have to call somebody.
I just pick it up,
you know?
And that just that alone,
you know,
to,
to know that you can carry yourself.
To know that you can do 50 chin ups to
know that you can move your body around
in a way that most people find to be
almost impossible.
It's like,
I want my body to work better.
You know,
it's like having a race car and you can
choose what horsepower engine it is
based on how much work you put on it.
I mean,
that's essentially what your body is.
You can choose how much tread you have
in your tires.
You can choose how good the suspension
is,
how supple it is,
and how well it can maneuver based on
how much pyogenic exercises you do or
how many different explosive maneuvers,
you know,
clean and presses and things along those
lines.
You can get that body to work.
Right?
Yeah.
I think that,
uh,
you know,
if you look at animals in the wild,
right?
You know,
if you're looking at a pack of animals
getting hunted,
which one's going to get killed and
which one are they going to pick out?
The Flyer,
the frail,
the slow week one.
Right.
The old one.
So if you're a human and we don't get
hunted by alliance,
but if you're a human,
if you say,
you know,
my one was my peak athletic cism,
maybe 25 maybe 30 you know,
somewhere in our 33rd 35 somewhere in
there.
That's like your,
that's your top performance for most
people.
Yeah.
The closer you can maintain that ability
as long as you possibly can and do
whatever it takes to get there,
the farther you are away from death.
I mean,
that's just,
that's just simple nature.
You know,
the slow the week they get eaten,
they die,
they get disease,
it become disabled.
I don't want to be,
you know,
I'm 50 now,
I don't want to be a 60 year old guy
that's walking around,
limping around,
you know,
needing assistance.
Somebody that,
you know,
lift my groceries for me and this is
what we have.
Or even a woman.
I mean,
women should be out there.
Strength Training,
getting stronger,
swinging a heavy kettle bells.
[inaudible] that's the other thing that
you brought up explosiveness,
because I think we're finally starting s
we finally went away from jogging.
Right?
You know,
we went from the 1960s to the,
you know,
early two thousands.
Everybody's jogging.
That's what you do for health.
Then people started discovering strength
training.
So now we get people that are in there
lifting a little bit.
But I think what you also have to do,
and this is something,
cause I,
I've got this whole training system
that,
uh,
you know,
helping people with,
but I think you have to do the explosive
work too.
So I do,
you know,
I get in there with medicine balls and I
think a lot of people want to use,
I take medicine balls and I try to break
the fucking things.
I mean,
I throw him as hard as I can,
you know,
I'm jumping,
like I said,
I'm jumping with a vest on,
you know,
this stuff,
you have to build up two and a half test
to be done in a safe manner.
You know what?
I'm sprinting,
I'm on an Airdyne bike.
You have you been on an Airdyne June?
Yeah.
I love those.
Those are the,
I was gonna say you gotta get one for
here.
Here's all to have you bought new ones.
No,
no.
Here's what I would tell you to do.
There's a company called octane fitness.
It makes an Airdyne X.
It's probably better than that aerosault
bike.
Really?
Yeah.
Pull that up.
I like,
what's it called?
Octane fitness.
Codeine x nine x.
What's better about it?
It's just solid.
I mean,
it's solid as can be.
I mean it's just,
it's,
it's just,
you can just,
you know,
in my view,
cause I've done everything train,
I mean our broken world records on the
concept too,
so I know how to do the intense stuff
that airdyne those type things.
The best thing you could do for the
short sprints.
I mean,
they're still out there.
Yeah,
there's so metabolically demanding.
I mean,
I don't know if they charged.
I think the only thing that I've always
had reservations about it,
it's like the sitting down part as far
as what I feel that like you would get
more exercise if you're supporting your
body weight.
Well,
I mean,
you know,
I don't,
there's a skier you can do stuff like
that,
you know,
but I mean if you,
if you get on that thing and you go as
hard as you fucking can for 30 seconds
or a minute,
a minute Seymour's man,
every time I did it for a minute,
I feel like I'm literally going to
drowned.
I'm going to die.
You know?
It's just like,
cause I,
you know,
here's what I do.
I'd tell I call these things chainsaw
intervals.
So I tell people,
pretend there's some fucking maniac with
a chainsaw to cut you off.
You know,
you've got to go as hard as you can
either.
You know,
there's a,
I've got a,
I've got,
I don't have that at home.
I've got to know the regular downwards
and I keep ranking the damn thing cause
I go too hard.
You know,
I was just not strong enough.
But when I go to the commercial gym,
there's a guy that they just made that
and they showed they and told him he had
me doing it ahead of,
there's another mma guy that,
I mean I can't remember any member's
name,
but he was like a pride champion guy,
like pride six or seven and they want it
and he's at the gym I'm at sometimes in
southern California.
But,
but I mean that thing is you just try
do,
do you have those?
I'm sure those guys would come up here
and let you demo it,
you know,
and just get on there and go.
You know,
and this is the thing I talked about
when I talk about high intensity
interval training.
You know a lot of people,
they don't get the high intensity part.
You know,
they do,
they'll do two bottles where they'll go
90% a hundred percent of the first one
and the by the time the third one,
they're down to like 60% because the
rest intervals are too short.
So I'm like,
man,
go like somebody's going to kill you for
20 seconds and then rest three or four
minutes and then go again.
Cause then you keep hitting that high
intense.
What I do with exercise when it comes to
weight lifting,
I take big breaks now.
They used to,
for weightlifting,
I used to do like I just tried to burn
myself out.
Yeah,
go to failure.
Short is like if I get 30 seconds break,
hi,
come on.
Next set,
next set.
I mean,
I don't do that anymore.
The problem with that is you're just
tired.
He knows what your training at the time.
Now there's a time to do the training.
You know,
like I said,
I,
you know,
when I break it up and I tell people how
to train,
I'm like look,
you train it for explosive and that's
the only thing you care about.
You don't get tired cause you're gonna,
you're gonna,
you're gonna waste here.
You're not going to be tense enough.
The same thing with the sprinting,
the same thing.
We'll lift and give yourself enough of a
break so that you can focus and do what
you need to do.
Then when it's conditioning time,
then you can go get tired of that shit.
Do it with lightweights.
Yeah.
That's one of the problems would like,
you know,
I think crossfit,
there's a lot of good elements to their,
I mean there's a lot of people that do
well with it,
but some of the exercises they pick,
you know,
like when you get tired doing snatches,
the odds of you getting fucked up.
Our high,
very high.
So I tell people,
do something that's,
you know,
it's hard and it's tiring and when you
get tired and your form breaks down,
you're not going to get hurt.
You know,
she may do medicine,
ball slams,
you're jumping up and down on a box and
then you fuck up.
Right.
Your shit bloody.
You know,
what's,
what's the point of that?
So I just have a,
you know,
I've been told ropes are a great one for
that too.
There's no consequences to exhaust.
Exactly.
I think that's,
that's the way to do that.
And I've been,
you know,
I've been training for almost 40 years,
Joe and I haven't taken a week off.
Taking a week off is all that,
you know,
I'll take a week off.
And the same thing with you.
I know as you take too much time,
you just don't feel good.
Miss.
The other thing about this diet,
my recovery passage capacity is huge.
I mean,
I can train super-intense every single
day,
you know,
without a break,
which is Kinda Nice.
I mean,
this is the other thing that I get
people telling me all the time is,
you know,
they're,
I mean,
they're hitting prs on dead lists are
doing all this personal record for non
athletes.
Yeah,
I'm sorry.
So I'm not used to,
you know what I'm talking about,
but I mean,
it's like,
you know,
I get these people all the time,
they're like,
man,
I'm hitting pushup records chinup
records.
But dead lift went up 100 pounds and
three months from,
from just eating meat and stuff like
that.
So I think there's something to it.
I mean I have people that are telling
me,
my dad,
I put my dad on his tie,
right?
He's 74 years old,
two months in the Diet.
He goes,
hey man,
this is a biggest my biceps ever been in
my life.
And he's just eating meat.
That is crazy.
So he's like,
he's just putting on muscle just cause
he's taken in so much animal tissue.
So listen man,
keep us posted on this.
Keep me posted on like how your,
you know,
your own personal journeys gone and
whatever evidence that you collect with
other people.
And I'm very curious,
I'm curious about this.
I might give it a try for one month.
Yeah.
Here's what I'll tell you joe.
So January,
January world carnivore month,
right?
So we're trying to get as many people,
we get thousands of people on there and
just give us your data at n equals many
dot coms do a month in world carnivore
month.
There's instructions on how to do that
and just submit your day.
You can,
you said you're allowed to eat anything
else?
Yeah.
So I tell people you can eat meat,
eggs,
dairy,
cheese.
You know you can drink coffee,
stuff like that,
because we didn't,
we just no vegetables for a month.
No fruits and vegetables from on.
No plants for a month.
You can see it.
You put a little seasoning on chance.
I'll give it a chance.
I'll try.
I'll try to show month one,
month,
January.
Well,
try to find a month.
Tell me,
tell me if you need help,
Joe.
Thanks brother.
Appreciate it was great.
Thank you.
All right.